Sofort eine Verbindung zum Fritz Server aufbauen.
Verbindung hergestellt.
Soll das aktuelle Programm angewählt werden?
Bitte geben sie den Zukunftscode ein.
Kabelsalat ist gesund.
Zugriffgewähr zum aktuellen Programm.
Voller Durchblick bei Chaosradio. Genau. Kann man jemand was Schlaues sagen? Ich bin der Beste. Ich bin der Beste.
Ich bin der Beste. Ich bin der Beste. Ich bin der Beste. Ich bin der Beste. Ich bin der Beste. Ich bin der Beste. Ich bin der Beste. Ich wollte dich erst mal ein bisschen über die Hardware herziehen. Also wer sich mit unserer Sendung oft auseinandersetzt, merkt ja, dass irgendwie unser Intro manchmal ein bisschen ruckelt. Das Ding am Anfang hat dem Experten verraten, dass sich dabei mal ein Macintosh heilt. Und damit wir nicht nur über ein System schimpfen müssen, können wir auch gleich noch unsere PCs schimpfen, weil dieses C-Pad, das hier neben mir steht und eigentlich den Leftland-Router spielen sollte, kann keine zwei PC-Cards gleichzeitig, weil sie auf dem selben Interrupt gelegt werden. Und einer der beiden Treiber, es handelt sich um ein Linux-System, offensichtlich nicht damit klarkommt.
Das ist ja schrecklich! Also ich hab wieder auch so Probleme mit dem Fingfack. Da gehen nämlich die internen Lautsprecher nicht.
Ah, du kannst da mit geraubten MP3s nicht am spielen.
Genau.
Verdammt, verdammt und nochmals verdammt. TS Chaos Radio 56, schönen guten Abend. Im Studio Andreas, Mitch und Tim. Und Holger. Ich erinnere mich noch, als wäre es gestern gewesen. Da haben wir hier gesessen. Wann war das? 19h30.
Sag es einfach.
5 Jahre Chaos Radio, schönen guten Abend. Was? was? Ich mach grad die Musik leiser hier und Chaos Radio 56, 5 Jahre gibt's das jetzt, das Chaos Radio. Schau mal die Schampels auf jetzt.
Ja, super.
Währenddessen kann Andreas ja...
Wollen wir auch ein Zeigleser organisieren lassen?
Natürlich, das haben wir schön sauber.
Weiß, geriffelten Design.
Was hab ich sauber hingekriegt?
Was meister?
Das muss aber knallen natürlich.
Ich muss knallen.
Du musst gut zielen.
Ich mache mal meinen Laptop zu.
Ah!
Genau.
Eigentlich wollten wir ja was über Peer-to-Peer Netzwerke.
Nicht jetzt, wir haben jetzt zu trinken.
Ich erzähle ja bloß, warum wir jetzt trinken.
Das ist ein guter Grund.
Genau.
Das mit dem Peer-To-Peer-Networking, wir haben uns mit dem Thema beschäftigt und festgestellt, dass Peer-To-Peer-Networking eigentlich das ist, was wir sowieso schon die ganze Zeit machen und dass es nichts Neues ist, dass es deshalb auch nichts Neues zu sagen gibt. Deshalb haben wir uns beschlossen, über den Anlass zu feiern.
Meinst du nicht, dass es den einen oder anderen gibt, der damit nichts anfangen kann?
Was, womit?
Peer-To-Peer-Networking? Guckt euch an, wie Napster funktioniert.
Im Prinzip ist es so, dass früher als das Internet erfunden wurde, da gab es nur Prosts.
Prost.
Schön, dass das noch Milch kein Teil hat.
Früher waren alle gleich. Früher hatten alle eine IP-Adresse und die waren statisch. Und sie waren alle 24 Stunden am Tag erreichbar.
Trinken, trinken. Ja, klar. Was ist denn da?
Ich hab Flasch-Möd mit.
So, nachdem wir wieder in unseren Kinderkapriolen gekrannt haben, entschuldigen wir uns die IP-Adressen.
Und heutzutage ist es halt so, dass man eine W-Leitung hat mit einer dynamischen IP-Adresse. Naja, und das wird jetzt halt wieder abgeschafft durch aufgebohrte Protokolle, die so tun, als wäre das nicht da. Und plötzlich kann wieder jeder mit jedem reden und das nennt sich dann Peer-To-Peer Networking.
Das war aber sehr kompliziert ausgedroht.
Naja, es geht eigentlich.
Also du bist zum Beispiel ein Peer. Eigentlich sind wir auch alle Peers. Und was wir hier machen, ist sozusagen Peer-To-Peer Networking. Das heißt, es gibt hier keinen zentralen Server irgendwie. Es gibt hier keinen Chef. Und deswegen geht das alles so, wie es gerade gehen muss. Ich sage genau an der Stelle, in dem Moment das, was ich möchte, irgendwie und muss nicht irgendwie einen Umweg über irgendein zentrales System nehmen. Und das schafft natürlich gewisse Freiraum. Wie man ja unter anderem bei dieser MP3-Tradingwarn, der jetzt ausgebrochen ist, ganz gut ablesen kann.
Apropos Peer.
Der Schreibwarenladen neben meiner Schule früher, der hieß auch Bier. Super.
Starkbier oder Schmackbier?
Habe.
Thüringen!
Hat keine gemeinsame Grenze mit Brandenburg.
Thüringen hat keine gemeinsame Grenze mit Brandenburg und wir machen trotzdem die Musik ein bisschen leiser, damit Thüringen uns auch ordentlich vernehmen kann, denn hier ist Chaosradio 56.
Wir sind da auf Chaosradio 56.
Ja und ihr ist Tim. Genau.
Und ich bin auch Tim. Sind wir nicht alle ein bisschen...
Meine Frau heißt auch Tim und ich fordere, dass ich vorm Fondle heiße.
Ja. Das wird schwierig, heute ein bisschen ernsthaft zu werden, weil wir sind so dermaßen in Feierlaune. Wir wollten euch eigentlich auch nur ein bisschen erschrecken, damit wir das Thema komplett gewechselt haben. Wir haben bloß unsere Haare angehend, uns weiße geändert, das ist eigentlich alles. Ja, weil ich meine, wenn, wenn nicht nach 5 Jahren Chaosradio sollte man auch irgendwie in zunehmendem Maße mal darüber schwadronieren. Warum ist das eigentlich alles so beschäftigt?
Und warum das auch so wichtig ist?
Sag mal, warum beschäftigt euch das eigentlich alles so? Warum ist das so wichtig? Andreas?
Dann müssen wir auf eine kurze, eine einleuchtende oder eine richtige Antwort?
Ja.
Dann fangen wir mal mit der kurzen an. Und die lautet, weil irgendwie, naja, also als die damals den Suchtdruck erfunden haben, das hat der Konsequenzen, die damals noch nicht absehbar waren. Die sind in der französischen Revolution erneten. Also vorher irgendwie das Wissen im Klostern, in handgeschriebenen Büchern, die von Mönchen sorgfältig transkribiert wurden. Und ja, die Erfindung der Buchdruckerpresse war ein großer Umsturz. Und keine dreihundert Jahre später kam auch die Revolution. Also die Zeiträume waren damals noch ein bisschen größer. Und im Endeffekt war die französische Revolution ja darauf zurückzuführen, dass Ideen verbreitet wurden, die vorher nicht verbreitet werden können, weil sie kontrolliert werden konnten. Und mit dem Buchdruck gab es dann auch die Aufklärung, mit der Aufklärung die französische Revolution. Und nun ist es so, dass dieses Internet eine Erfindung ist, die von der Tragweite her mit der Erfindung des Buchdrucks vergleichbar ist, weil es plötzlich sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr billig geworden ist, große Mengen Informationen und auch relevanter Informationen zu übertragen. Und die Größenordnung ist die gleiche wie beim Übergang zwischen...
Was? Du bist an. Das Knacken, das kam von woanders her. Ich glaube, dein Mikrofon wäre aus. Es war aus.
Nein, es war nicht aus.
Doch, es war aus. Ich habe mich zumindest nicht mehr drauf gehört. Also du bist schuld.
Ja, schuld bin ich ja gerne, aber das Mikro war nicht aus.
Okay, ich war glaube ich beim Internet stehen geblieben, und dass das ja alles sehr toll ist und dass deshalb bald die Revolution kommt und dass es auf jeden Fall viel zu kurzfristig ist, sich sowas wie Peer-To-Peer Networking unter den Gesichtspunkt eines kurzfristigen Hypes anzugucken. Und dass es viel eher notwendig ist, mal zu gucken, was denn so die globalen gesamtgesellschaftlichen, geschichtlichen Auswüchse sind, wenn man das Ganze mal ein bisschen skaliert auf den mehrere Hundert-Jahre-Faktor. Und diese fünf Jahre Chaosradio gibt dazu mehr oder weniger den Anlass, weil fünf Jahre in Internetjahren viel, aber im globalen Rahmen doch sehr, sehr wenig ist. Wenn man sich überlegt, wann wir von den Bäumen runtergeklettert sind, dann ist das alles nicht viel. Und deshalb wollen wir mal ein bisschen weiter zurückgucken.
Gab es da nicht sogar mal eine Zahl, wie viel ein Internetmonat in Jahren außerhalb ist?
Na ja, da gibt es so unterschiedliche Interpretationen. Faktor eins zu vier bis eins zu zehn ist alles genannt. Und das stimmt auch alles irgendwie.
Genau, alles ist richtig.
Wobei es für die Politiker eher so einen Eindruck macht, als hätten sie da irgendwie noch eins zu eins, weil sie irgendwie durch das Internet noch nicht schneller begreifen geworden sind und deswegen auch so einige Auseinandersetzungen noch nicht wirklich in der Lage sind zu führen. Das merkt man immer wieder. Auch wenn man sich mit den Leuten mal real trifft. Ich bin auch von jüngster Zeit Gott sei Dank verschont worden.
Ich dokumentiere jetzt mal live, wie hier unser Nachrichtenmensch abgefüllt wird.
Das ist ja zum Katzen hier.
Dabei war letzte Stunde schon nicht gerade mal eine Frischstunde.
Soll ich erst trinken oder erst trinken?
22.31 Uhr, trink du, ich machs Wetter sehr langsam.
Zum Wohl.
Das Wetter aktuell zwischen vier und sieben Grad.
Stimmt nicht, das Wetter steht in Grammarsch wieder.
Ja, ich wollte das Wort nicht sagen. Die Werte sinken in der Nacht auf vier bis ein Grad. Dabei bleibt es trocken. Hast du ausgetrunken, Matthias?
Moment, nicht.
Morgen bewölbt, nachmittags und abends Regen bei sechs bis neun Grad. Hast du ausgetrunken?
Ja, aber ich hab vor 15 Jahren mal irgendwie gelernt, man sollte nie was mit Kohlen-Säure trinken.
Und keine Schokolade-Echen wegen den Speichelflug.
Ein generelles Verbot der Tiermüll-Verfötterung wird es vermutlich erst ab dem Wochenende geben. Die Bundesregierung zog eine Eilverordnung aus juristischen Gründen zurück. Nun soll bis Freitag ein entsprechendes Gesetz verabschiedet werden, heißt es. Der Berliner Senat hat heute aufgrund der BSE-Gefahr Vorbeugemaßnahmen getroffen. So wurde den Schulen und Kindertagesstätten empfohlen, bei der Essenversorgung vorerst kein Rindfleisch mehr anzubieten. Der Tod des sechsjährigen Josef aus dem sächsischen Sebnitz bleibt weiter unklar. Drei Beschuldigte wurden heute wieder freigelassen. Der dringende Tatverdacht musste aufgrund von Zweifeln an den Zeugenaussagen fallen gelassen werden. Der Hauptbelastungszeuge hatte sich in Widersprüche verwickelt. Bundestagspräsident Thierse hat die CDU-Haltung zur Ausländerpolitik kritisiert. Mit Blick auf den harten Kurs von Brandenburgs Innenminister Schönbohm forderte er am Abend in Frankfurt oder eine menschliche Auslegung der Ausländergesetze. Das israelische Parlament hat den Status von Jerusalem per Gesetz festgeschrieben. Danach dürfen die Stadtgrenzen künftig nur noch geändert werden, wenn eine absolute Mehrheit der Knesset-Abgeordneten dafür stimmt. Der Status von Jerusalem ist zwischen Israelis und Palästinensern umstritten. Verkehrsmeldungen aus dem Stadtgebiet Berlin. Sperrung wegen Instandsetzungsarbeiten auf der Autobahn 100 liegt in Bergrichtung Wehmersdorf im Tunnel Ortskern Britz bis 5 Uhr in beiden Richtungen. Und gesperrt ist auch die Autobahn 102 Tempelhof Richtung Britz zwischen Tempelhof und Gradestraße bis 4 Uhr. Umleitungen sind ausgeschildert.
22.33.
Oder da? Ach hier.
Konzerte, Hip-Hop, Rock, Fritz-Geschichten, Interviews und alle Termine für die Rosentasche.
Und wo find ich Ankel Fritz?
Klebt auf allen Ankel-Sellys-Magazinen in Berlin und Potsdam. Und gibt's in Kneipen, Cafés, Kinos, Unis, Recordstores, Szene-Outlets und bei Konzerten. Und wenn du willst, schicken wir's dir auch zu.
Das ist aber wirklich interessante Musik, die du da mitgebracht hast, Tim.
Die hab ich überhaupt nicht mitgebracht, die hast du mitgebracht. Mit deinem Windows MP3 Player da hinten. Du hast es gut. Wir sind ja schon wieder hier Internet unterversorgt.
Ich hab ja nicht mal hier, ist ja gar nichts.
Weil hier nämlich gefiltert wird, das ist irgendwie ganz garstig.
Ich hab gesagt, das ist ein sehr sicheres Netzwerk, kommt keiner raus.
Super, das erinnert ein bisschen an ein Gefängnis.
Mitch, würdest du bitte auch diesen Kopfhörer aufsetzen, damit du nicht so ausgeschlossen bist? Ja, so geht das doch.
Besser ist das.
Ja doch, irgendwie schon. Chaosradio 56 hier, die Geburtstagssendung. Zum Wahrheit erzählen, sind wir nicht da. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Was wollten wir DSL in Friedrichsheim?
Genau, Peer-To-Peer Network. Also Peer-To-Peer Network ist sozusagen eine Gegenströmung zum kleinen Server und das muss man sich so vorstellen, da gibt es so schöne Bilder, da ist dann irgendwie ein großer Computer, da steht Server drüber, da ist ein ganz ganz dicker Pfeil, der zeigt nach rechts, da ist dann so ein kleines Männchen, das ist dann der Kunde und dann hat er so einen ganz ganz dünnen Pfeil, der geht wieder nach links und da steht kaufen dran. So, das ist so das klassische Herangehensweise an irgendwie DUM User Internet.
Multimedia.
Beziehungsweise, die Idee ist ja noch viel älter angefangen, hat das ja alles, als die Telekom, nee Post damals BTX gemacht hat, gab es nämlich 1200 slash 75, das heißt man hatte einen Hin-Kanal mit 1200 Bit pro Sekunde und einen Rück-Kanal mit 75 Bit pro Sekunde. Und das heißt, man konnte da irgendwie eingeben, welche Seite man haben will und hat das dann bekommen, aber wenn man Dienste anbieten wollte, musste man halt Server-Space bei der Telekom mieten, damals hieß das alles noch anders. Und naja, mit den bekannten Resultaten, so richtig populär war das ja nicht. Und heutzutage machen sie das ja wieder so, also bei ADSL zum Beispiel kriegt man wieder die 768 Kilobit hin und dann noch die 128 Kilobit zurück und wenn man dann mal einen Server betreiben will, stellt man fest, dass man da ziemlich schnell am Ende seiner Bandbreite angekommen ist.
Also hin und zurück trifft es nicht so richtig. Es ist eher so ein rein und raus. Sie wollen viel rein, aber nicht so viel raus.
Genau, das alte Sender-Empfänger-Prinzip. Es gibt halt irgendwie einen, der etwas sagt und den anderen, der zuhören muss.
Aber meine Kreditkartendaten übermitteln kann ich über 128 doch wunderbar. Das ist doch was, die wollen.
Und das ist genau das, was sie wollen. Es gibt aber auch andere Ansätze, z.B. in Schweden ist es so, dass da gerade Pilotprojekte laufen und innerhalb der nächsten drei Jahre wollen sie 80% aller Haushalte vernetzen. Und zwar wollen die einfach Ethernet in jeden Haushalt legen. Das heißt 10 Megabit hin, 10 Megabit zurück. Und zwar in der Grundversion, in der Ausbauversion mit 100 MBit in beide Richtungen. Das Ganze für 50 Mark im Monat Flatrate. Und ich finde, dass irgendwie in Deutschland die Provider und die Politiker endlich mal aufwachen sollten und irgendwie begreifen sollten, wie das alles funktioniert und sich nicht irgendwie von einer Krücke zur nächsten Krücke versuchen zu retten, ohne zu verstehen, was tatsächlich abgeht. So was hätte ich gerne. Du wohnst ja auch im Friedrichshain, habe ich gehört. Ja.
Das, ähm, verdammt, ich ziehe da weg.
Auch ein Opaloffer. Ich würde dir empfehlen, da drin wohnen zu bleiben, um das auszusitzen. Und zwar aus einem ganz einfachen Grund. Die Telekom hatte damals eine für Telekom Verhältnisse gar nicht so dumme Idee. Nämlich, dass wenn man Glasfaser in jedes Haus legt, dass man dann ja unglaubliche Mengen Bandbreite in den Häusern hat und dass das irgendwie alles super zukunftskompatibel ist. Haben sich das noch vom Staat ein bisschen vergolden lassen wegen Aufbau Ost und so weiter und so fort. Und haben dann das ganze DDR-Telefonnetz weggeschmissen, was ja an sich schon mal keine schlechte Idee war. Und dann da ein neues hin installiert. Und da haben sie in einigen Gegenden halt diese neue Technologie ausprobiert. Das Basswirt hieß damals Fiber to the Loop. Und das Produkt, was von der Telekom angeschafft wurde, das heißt Opal. Und gebaut hat das die Firma Alcatel. Und aufgrund von internen Entscheidungsfindungsabläufen, die nicht mit dem übereinstimmen, was man sich normalerweise vorstellt, ist da also auch nicht die Lösung gebaut worden, die sie wollten, sondern eine abgespeckte Lösung, die letzten Endes bedeutet, dass du zum Beispiel in Friedrichshain eine Glasfaser bei dir unten im Haus hast. Und dann steht da ein Schrank von der Telekom. Und da kriegt man halt nur ISDN raus. Weil die Telekom sich mittlerweile weigert, mit Alcatel Geschäfte zu machen und deshalb keine schnelleren Module kauft, obwohl es die gelbe theoretisch. Möchtest du noch jemanden Shampoos? Klar.
Ich hab noch ein bisschen. Ich trinke im Haus.
Vielleicht nicht über das Auto. Wir haben Verständnis.
Ja, aber warum soll ich ihm das dann aussitzen? Die Telekom scheißt darauf nicht. Das ist mir doch jetzt schon klar.
Na ja, klar.
Na ja, ich hege ja die Hoffnung, dass es ihnen so peinlich ist, dass sie dieses Netz stillschweigend irgendwann verkaufen und dann irgendjemand diesen Scheißhardware da rauswirft und da irgendwas Richtiges reinschraubt. Und dann hat er nämlich auch wieder 10 Megabit Internet in den Häusern. In den Häusern, wo es nämlich jetzt ADSL gibt, gibt es demzufolge kein Opal. Das heißt, da liegt keine Glasfaser im Keller.
Und das sind so die armen Schweine der Zukunft dann quasi.
Genau, also die, die jetzt schnelles Internet haben, werden demnächst langsames Internet haben.
Ich hab ja ein Kongress dieses Jahr und ich hab ja ein Pressausschuss. Da muss ich jetzt noch 2500 Mark zahlen, um dahin gehen zu dürfen.
Wenn du möchtest.
Das kommt natürlich darauf an, ob du über das Ereignis berichten oder diese Veranstaltung besuchen möchtest.
Wenn ich das über das Ereignis berichten sollte, dann wird natürlich, hoffe ich, Fritz das zahlen, und sonst gibt es kein Gericht.
Ja, du kannst auch anonym kommen.
Echt? Kann ich auch anonym kommen? Gut, dann komme ich als Tanja Nolde.
Wer ist das?
Kennst du nicht Tanja Nolde?
Tanja Nolde ist die 15-Jährige, die Anzeigen in die Zeitung gesetzt hat.
Die unbedingt 64er-Spieler haben wollte.
Genau, die unbedingt 64 spielten. Grafenreuth. Außen known as Freiherr von Grafenreuth.
Oder wie ist die Sonja 6669?
Können wir nicht über schöne Sachen reden? Es ist nämlich wieder Kongress. Ihr wisst schon, 17. Chaos Communication Kongress. Wir sind ja der Chaos Computer Club und wir machen Veranstaltungen. Und eine machen wir jedes Jahr, das ist der Kongress. Oder lange ausgeschrieben der Chaos Communication Kongress. Der findet seit ein paar Jahren in Berlin statt. So auch in diesem Jahr im Haus am Kölnischen Park. Und zwar zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr. Also am 27. 28.
und 29.
Dezember. Und da ist eine Menge los. Da kommen viele Leute und Hacker. Und da wird halt geredet und diskutiert und umgehackt. Und dieses und jenes getan und solche Sachen gemacht. Und was wir da so alles tun, das kann man jetzt gar nicht alles so ohne weiteres zusammenfassen, aber dafür gibt es ja Internet. Und da könnt ihr ja mal eure Browsen irgendwie einschalten. Und auf www.ccc.de slash kongress slash klicken. Und dann kriegt ihr irgendwie alles, was ihr braucht.
Genau, und danach reden wir drüber.
Genau. Kannst du IRC machen? Ja, mach, geh mal in den... Wir haben auch einen IRC-Server offen, IRC.ccc.de. Und da im Channel Chaos Radio, da klinken wir uns jetzt mal ein. So ein bisschen Internet haben wir ja auch.
So ein bisschen Internet?
So ein bisschen Internet. Leider ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wir das Port 80 freigelassen. Deswegen können wir jetzt irgendwie kein Internetradio hören.
Und für wie groß hältst du die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass Port 6667 offen ist?
Also SSH und sowas, so geht es.
Also ich weiß, über den Rechner, wo mittlerweile der Nameserver ausgetragen ist und der darum nicht mehr funktioniert, da ging 6667 mal.
Ja, der hängt aber an der NAIS. Die Inleitung ist von dem Internet von Fritz vollständig unabhängig. Was war denn das für eine so schlechte Scheiße? Ich sass auch schon an diesem Kumpch mit.
Ja, Chaosradio 56, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Also könnte uns jetzt jemand einen neuen Champagner bringen bitte?
Das wär nett.
Das war ein Aufruf und der war ernst gemein.
Ja genau, aber so lange können wir noch ein bisschen was zum Thema erzählen, dass wir überhaupt nicht irgendwann völlig besoffen sind.
Wovon? Wir haben keinen Shampus mehr.
Machen wir keine schlechte Laune.
Wir haben keinen Shampus mehr. Das reden wir doch mal über Peer-To-Peer Networking.
Aber wir haben ja noch Club-Mate.
Super, wir könnten vielleicht noch jemanden schicken, eine Flasche Korn holen, den können wir in die Club-Mate schütten, dann schmeckt das wie Champagner.
Also Peer-To-Peer Netzwerke, wir hatten ja schon beklagt, dass man neuerdings bei Internet-Providern nur diese komischen dynamischen IP-Adressen kriegt und sowieso gar keine festen Verbindungen. Und das ist ja furchtbar lästig ist, weil die ganzen schönen Filesharing-Protokolle, die es ja gibt auf IP-Basis, verlassen sich eigentlich alle drauf, dass die IP-Adresse bekannt ist und gleich bleibt. Und das ist ja nun leider nicht so. Und wenn man da zu Hause sitzt, hinter seiner ISDN-Leitung, möchte man ja was dagegen tun. Und in genau diese Marktlücke haben Entwickler verschiedene Produkte gestoßen, die mittlerweile in aller Nunde sind. Ich denke, Napster ist da das bekannteste. Und es gibt aber auch so Tools wie Hotline und MojoNation und... Gnutella und Freenet und wie sie alle heißen. Ich glaube, scour.net wurde jetzt geschlossen wegen Verklagt. Und alle diese Programme haben eine Eigenschaft gemeinsam. Sie benutzen irgendeine Art und Weise von Technologie, um dieses Problem der sich wechselnden IP-Adresse und der Erreichbarkeit zu umgehen. Und wie sie das im Einzelnen tun, können wir ja noch ein bisschen auswälzen. Aber die Grunderkenntnis muss erst mal lauten, dass alles nix Neues. Das haben die Leute früher schon gemacht, nur die Tools werden besser.
Okay, fangen wir mit Napster an.
Genau, Napster. Napster ist eine ziemlich clevere Idee. Und zwar hat sich da einer gedacht, ja man bräuchte eigentlich ein zentrales Verzeichnis, wo gespeichert ist, wo welche Fals liegen. Aber es besteht da keinerlei Notwendigkeit, dann dieses Fall auch anzubieten. Sonst reicht es aus, auf dem Rechner zu zeigen, wo das gerade rumliegt.
Also die muss man dazu sagen, ich meine am Anfang gab es halt FTP Server, genau dieses zentrale System. Es gibt da einen FTP Server. Das Problem ist, bevor man sich von einem FTP Server etwas herunterladen kann, muss man erst einmal auf diesen FTP Server hinaufladen. Und gerade bei diesem MP3-Trading war das natürlich auch juristisch ein Problem, weil dann irgendwie diese Jungs, die sowieso diese Welt finanziell ausbeuten, gleich hinmarschiert sind und irgendwie gesagt haben, du bist böse, du schaltest deinen Computer aus.
Naja, das ist aber ein Problem, das Napster nicht löst. Also bei Napster weiß man nach wie vor, wo die Fails liegen und kann die Leute auch ansprechend verlagen.
Ja, aber es sammeln sich halt nicht über so lange. Also ein FTP Server muss erst einmal bekannt werden, nach einer Weile, damit viele Leute ihn noch versorgen und viele Leute auch wieder runterladen. Und das dauert seine Zeit, während du bei Napster mit dem Verzeichnis, wo liegt jetzt gerade welche Datei, wo man einmal schnell drin suchen kann, gib mir jetzt mal Madonna Music Return, ratatatatatata. Dann hast du da eine Liste von 20 Rechtern, die jetzt genau in diesem Moment auch online sind, da sind, auch sagen, wie schnell sie angebunden sind und machen diverse andere Sachen. Das ist halt der Vorteil dieses speziellen Peer-To-Peer-Protokolls. Weil danach, nachdem man diese Information hat, kann man sich halt direkt mit diesem Rechner verbinden und es geht eben dann nicht mehr über den Server. Das ist eigentlich das, was sozusagen Napster eine Peer-To-Peer Technologie macht.
Das ist ja doch eigentlich was, was ich nicht will, oder? Dass überhaupt noch ein Server angesprochen werden muss. Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, darum rumzukommen dann?
Na ja, ich meine, du willst ja etwas haben, du willst ja einen Dienst haben. Du willst eine Datei gesendet bekommen, dann brauchst du einen Server. Die Frage ist halt nur...
Irgendjemand muss es dir ultimativ schicken. Aber eine der entscheidenden Neuerungen bei Napster war halt, dass jeder Client auch gleichzeitig Server ist. Also jeder, der dieses Programm startet, bietet auch Files an. Und in der Standard-Konfiguration ist es auch so, dass alles, was man sich downgelodet hat, sofort wieder zum Upload bereitgestellt wird, damit die Leute, die nichts konfigurieren, trotzdem zum Erhalt des Systems beitragen. Und die entscheidenden Neuerungen, also sowas wie Suche, gab es bei FTP ja auch. Da gab es ganz früher Archie, das war ziemlich die erste Suchmaschine, die mir untergekommen ist.
Die hatte auch ein eigenes Protokoll dafür.
Genau, konnte man aber auch per Tenet drauf, das ging auch. Und später gab es dann FTPsearch.ntnu.no, ein Forschungsprojekt an einer norwegischen Universität, das dann später ftpsearch.lykos.com wurde. Und wenn man nach Sachen sucht, die irgendwie doch eher legal sind, und deshalb wahrscheinlich auf einem FTP-Server liegen, findet man da die Dinge auch relativ gut, nicht immer. Die entscheidenden Probleme war halt, dass erstens der Server eine feste IP-Adresse haben musste, unter der er ständig erreichbar war. Und das zweite Problem ist, dass man nicht wirklich sah, welche davon auch online sind, sondern er ist halt irgendwann mal drübergegangen. Wenn der Rechner weg war, dann hat er das nicht gemerkt.
Hier war irgendwann mal die Datei, die du suchst, vielleicht.
Genau, und früher war das ja alles anders, als die Leute noch feste IP-Adressen hatten. Dann funktionierte das auch so. Und heutzutage musste halt ein elegantes Protokoll dazwischen geschaltet werden.
Damals kamen die Bineries aber direkt aus den News. Da musste man überhaupt nichts tun. Die landeten einfach nachts auf der Festplatte.
Genau, wurden von Skripten automatisch ausgepackt. Und ich denke, die entscheidende Erkenntnis an der Stelle, und das spiegelt sich auch in den anderen Peer-To-Peer-Protokollen wieder, ist, dass man auf der IP-Ebene noch so viel tun kann, solange man da irgendwie Daten durchkriegt. Es ist eine Möglichkeit geben, ein Protokoll zu schreiben, das genau die Probleme des grundlegenden Transportmediums umgeht und trotzdem in der Lage ist, das anzubieten, was man möchte. Nämlich irgendwie schnell versklicken.
Mit anderen Worten, es lässt sich alles nicht verhindern.
Genau. Aber man könnte das Netz verbieten.
Genau, das könnte man natürlich tun.
Das ist dann der nächste Schritt des Innenministers.
Du solltest mal doch Luft abschaffen.
Bei uns war das Geburtstag Chaos Radio Nummer 56. Vor fünf Jahren ging es los und da sind wir nun. Und reden über die Unterschiede zwischen Napster und Gnutella.
Genau und warum Gnutella gescheitert ist. Es ist es in der Tat. Und zwar ist es so, dass bei Napster ein zentraler Server existiert, der sozusagen die Suchmaschine beherbergt. Das heißt, es gibt da eine Firma in den USA, die betreiben einen Computer und da ist gespeichert, was wo liegt. Nur ist es natürlich relativ einfach, gegen diese Firma eine einsweilige Verfügung zu erwirken, die ihnen verbietet, diesen Computer zu betreiben. Okay, in der Praxis ist es nicht ganz so einfach, aber es wird probiert. Es wird probiert. Es gibt da offensichtlich einen Angriffspunkt und es sieht alles schwer nach Rückzugsgefechten aus. Mittlerweile hat Bertelsmann Napster gekauft und was das zu bedeuten hat, steht in den Sternen. Das ist auf jeden Fall seltsam. Und das löst aber das grundlegende Problem nicht, dass man eigentlich gar keinen zentralen Server will. Das heißt, Napster hat zwar die File Storage dezentralisiert, hat aber nach wie vor die Meta-Information, nämlich was liegt wo zentral gehalten und ein zentraler Punkt ist natürlich immer angreifbar, sei es technisch, sei es juristisch. Und deshalb sind Leute auf die Idee gekommen, ein Protokoll zu entwickeln, was keinen zentralen Server mehr benötigt. Und das war Gnutella. Die Story zu Gnutella ist ganz lustig, das wurde dann auf der Page veröffentlicht bei... wer war das gleich? AOL? Also sie wurden dann von AOL gekauft und von AOL wenige Stunden nach der Veröffentlichung dazu gebracht, das doch wieder zurückzuziehen. Jedenfalls ist es bei Gnutella so, dass es keinen zentralen Server gibt, bei dem man sich registriert, sondern man kennt so ein paar Nachbarn, mit denen man halt redet. Und alle sind halt miteinander vernetzt und wenn man was sucht, schickt man eine Suchanfrage an alle Nachbarn, die man kennt, die schicken das an alle anderen weiter und irgendwann wird irgendjemand antworten. Also im Prinzip Broadcast-basiert, Broadcast-basierte Suche. Was ja im Prinzip nicht wie eine schlechte Idee klingt und was auch einige Monate lang wirklich gut funktioniert hat. Das Problem war, dass gerade durch die Klagen gegen Napster Gnutella auch sehr populär geworden ist und immer mehr User auf dieses System drauf gekommen sind. Und zum Schluss war es so, dass die durchschnittliche Anzahl der Suchanfragen so groß war, dass man mit einer ISTN-Leitung zum Beispiel schon gar nicht mehr alle Suchanfragen gesehen hat, geschweige denn überhaupt den Platz besessen hätte, da noch Daten zwischendurch zu übertragen.
Does not scale.
Ich habe auch mal einen Gnutella-Server über Nacht laufen lassen und er hat in einer Nacht einen Gigabyte-Traffic erzeugt und zwar nur mit Suchanfragen, nicht mit Downloads. Und das ist eigentlich ein Beweis dafür, dass dieses Protokoll zum Untergang verurteilt ist. War also leider nichts und war ein netter Versuch und hat sicherlich auch die Diskussion stimuliert, aber wird sich auf jeden Fall nicht durchsetzen.
Gibt es eine andere Alternative?
Es gibt da noch mehr und zwar ein relativ interessanter.
Vor allem muss man dazu sagen, Napster wird es jetzt immer geben, weil selbst sollte diese eine Firma jetzt irgendwie weggeklagt werden, wonach es nicht unbedingt so sehr aussieht. Irgendwie wird es schon so weiter laufen. Es gibt jetzt schon irgendwie tausende andere Server, die einfach dasselbe Protokoll sprechen. Einfach Leute haben sich ran gemacht, haben das Protokoll analysiert, was da hin und her geht und wie die Suchanfrage verpackt werden muss, wie die Antwort kommt. Relativ einfaches Protokoll. Und so gibt es also diverse Open Napster Software Pakete als freier Source, als Free Software. Und die setzen halt auch eigene Server auf und das funktioniert halt genauso. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man den zu macht, macht man irgendwie tausend andere automatisch auf. Und daher, das war halt auch der Grund, warum Bertelsmann zugeschlagen hat, weil jetzt die Popularität noch nutzt. Weil die Konkurrenz steht im Prinzip schon da.
Das ist aber ganz schön schnelle Musik.
No pain, no gain.
Na ja gut, das ist gerade nicht meine Taktrate.
Aber die ist ein bisschen niedrig.
Ich bin in Low-Power-Mode.
Allerdings.
Solange ich nicht ins Lieb-Mode bin, ist ja noch was zu werden.
Na das kommt gleich.
Eine Festplatte hakt ja eh schon, das liegt daran, dass sie mit Macintosh eingebaut ist.
Wir fahren nicht nach Hause. Ich glaub's nicht, nehmen's nur an und fragen, filtern sie auch.
Das ist ja so unglaublich. Wir haben ja einfach kein richtiges Netz, die filtern irgendwie Arbiträr, irgendwelche Ports raus. Dieser Podcast geht auch nicht, ne? Die filtern einfach so Ports, die braucht man doch nicht und so. Und das ist bestimmt böse, wenn man die rauslässt. Was für ein Quatsch. Also ich meine, rauslassen ist nicht das Problem.
Also wenn man Ports 80 rauslässt, hat man sowieso schon verloren, weil man über Ports 80 beliebige Sachen rausschicken kann.
Also einfach aktive Benutzerverhinderung. Genauso wie Internet-Service-Provider, die ihre Kunden, das gab's lange, gibt's das eigentlich immer noch. Ja, bestimmt. So Metronet und so, die haben damit, glaub ich, irgendwie angefangen, die Leute zu zwingen, sozusagen über einen HTTP-Proxy ins Internet zu gehen. Das heißt, es gab sozusagen nicht Internet, sondern es gab ausschließlich World Wide Web, so wie die Firma es sah. Und das war natürlich eine sehr eingeschränkte Sicht der Dinge. Und das geht einfach gar nicht. Und der andere Telekomaten, naja, wie soll ich sagen, also es ist irgendwie so eine faschistische Sichtweise der Dinge, den Leuten immer die ganze Zeit vorschreiben zu wollen, wie sie dieses Netz zu benutzen haben.
Gibt's eigentlich noch diese...
Und auch diese Internetadressen-Problematik, so dass man einfach keine eigene Adresse kriegt, unter der man einfach genauso erreichbar ist wie jeder andere. Die Grundstruktur des Internets, das muss einfach garantiert werden.
Gibt's eigentlich noch diese Server, die einem die aller dritte Anfrage zur Werbung einblenden oder so?
Ja, äh, Germany Internet, war das, oder?
Oder den ersten HTTP-Request nach einem Connection gegen irgendwie ihre Homepage ersetzen und so ein Schnarzen. Das ist einfach super störend. Das bringt die Protokolle durcheinander, wenn da irgendwie Programme regelmäßig irgendwas tun.
Also es gibt mittlerweile bedauerlicherweise nicht nur Interneterster und zweiter Klasse, sprich mit fester und dynamischer IP-Adressen, sondern mittlerweile auch dritte und vierte Klasse. Und das beschränkt sich dann im Wesentlichen auf Webklicken. Und das ist eigentlich nicht Internet. Und jeder, der das als Internetverkauf bekommt, wird bedroht.
Es ist 23.08 Uhr, Zeit für das Lied für Marianne. Ich bin gespannt, wie du sie alle kennen kannst.
Na, das ist so eine Art, ähm, wie heißt das so schön? Metasyntaktische Variable.
Ähm, weil da jetzt, da kommt jetzt keine Musik mehr aus deiner Festart. Dann erzähl ich den Witz jetzt allen anderen auch, auch auf die Gefallen, dass sie den schon gehört haben. Also, ich erzähl jetzt diesen Witz. Ein Zirkus hat drei Elefanten. Bim, Bamm und Bum. Einer muss aus Kostengründen verkauft werden. Welcher?
Bum war es auch nicht.
Bum. Doch.
Doch.
Und warum?
Keine Ahnung.
Aus Kostengründen.
Ich finde ihn großartig. Ich glaube, das letzte Mal war im McDonalds, als ich den losgetanzt habe.
Körrst du jetzt alles aus?
Achso, wir essen grundsätzlich Beilagen.
Hamburger mit Champagner.
Genau, Hamburger mit Champagner. Das ist Chaosradio 56 hier. Wir haben getrunken. Denn es gibt zu feiern, dass wir seit 5 Jahren, dass zumindest das Chaosradio seit 5 Jahren quasi on air ist.
Nicht nur quasi. Wir sind nicht nur on air, wir sind auch on net. Hat zwar lange gedauert, und hier sind wir auch nicht so richtig on net, aber wir arbeiten dran. Aber im nächsten Jahr ist einfach mal 2001 und dann geht das hier nicht so weiter.
Da ziehen wir eh um in ein neues Haus, da wird das dann alles ganz ganz anders.
Aber erst Ende des Jahres.
Wo waren wir denn eigentlich eben stehen geblieben? Gnutella gescheitert, ne? Aber was ist dann das Protokoll der Zukunft? Bleibst du dann bei Napster, also bei der Art, wie Napster das macht?
Na ja, es gibt mehrere Entwicklungen. Relativ interessant finde ich das scour.net.
Dann nimmst du das Mikro bitte ein bisschen dichter an deinen Mund. Das geht auch nur, wenn du das zweite Ohr auch mit dem Kopfhörer bedeckst. Dann ist das...
Ja, scour.net. scour.net, die hatten auch einen sehr interessanten Ansatz. Das war einfach eine Suchmaschine, die ist rumgerannt und hat überall auf einem Rechner geguckt, ob da nicht zufällig Windows-Filesysteme exportiert werden per SMB-File-Sharing. Und hat die dann halt indiziert. Und da gab es halt eine Suchmaschine, da konnte man suchen. Und es gibt natürlich haufenweise Leute, die aus Versehen ihr File-Sharing offen haben. Und manche Leute machen halt auch absichtlich ihr File-Sharing auf und legen da Files rein und erzählen kann davon. Und irgendwann kommt halt jemand vorbei und guckt nach und findet die da und man kann die da downloaden. Das ist natürlich schwierig, dann irgendwie glaubhaft zu machen beziehungsweise irgendwie zu beweisen, dass diejenige absichtlich seinen File-Sharing offen gelassen hat. Nur leider mussten die jetzt dicht machen aus irgendeinem Grund. Vor wenigen Tagen wurden wahrscheinlich auch weggeklagt wegen illegal. Und das war es also auch nicht.
Du würdest sagen, die Juristen haben wieder mal die Beweislage umgedreht und du musst beweisen, dass du unschuldig bist.
Genau, man muss wahrscheinlich wieder beweisen, dass man unschuldig ist.
Ich glaube, wenn sie irgendwie den Napster-Leuten hinterher wollen, dann sollten wir auf Handauszählungen bestehen. Dann müssen sie auf Ewigkeiten finanzieren.
Alle, die ein reines Gewissen haben, geben eine Haarprobe ab.
Auf CNN war ein Bericht über die Wahl in britischen Zeitungen und da hatten sie dann so eine Schlagzeile. What a Mickey Mouse way to run a country.
Ich glaube, das trifft es ziemlich gut.
Die stellen sich auch ziemlich doof an. Sie hätten es ja so drauf mit den Computern und dann fangen sie an, die Löcher auszustanzen und am besten auch noch in jedem Count in ein anderes System. Aber das muss ja nicht unser Thema sein. Heute kommt nicht alles Gute aus den USA.
Sie nagen sich gerade eher selbst ans Kreuz.
Na ja, da sind schon eine Menge bright lights. Es wird auch auf Ewigkeiten so bleiben, aber das ist eben auch in anderen Ländern so. Und gerade weil Europa jetzt auch softwaremäßig aufsteht, ändert sich halt auch etwas, weil eben die europäische Gesetzeslage und die europäische Moralvorstellung und was so Freiheit oder Recht bedeutet, dann doch halt ein bisschen abweichen von dem etwas idealistischen Bild. Der Amerikaner, die eigentlich auf jegliche Freiheit verzichten, wenn sie nur die ganze Zeit sagen können, was sie wollen, ist natürlich genau genommen auch nicht dürfen. Aber zumindest werden wir diese Illusion am Leben erhalten.
Ich bin gespannt, ob ich mein Leben in der Lage erbauen kann, wo ich wirklich Dinge genießen kann. Und nicht zu einem Ort verkleidet. Ich meine nicht fliegen hier und da. Sodass ich sie nicht verlassen kann.
Aus Kostenründen, das Chaosradio 56, die Geburtstags-Sendung. Da können wir doch eigentlich, also wenn wir über Peer-To-Peer-Networking reden, dann reden wir doch eigentlich über unser Lieblingsthema, nämlich die Amseln und das geistige Eigentum.
Ja, unter anderem, also zumindest hat diese Napster-Diskussion das mal wieder ganz oben auf die Tagesordnung gesetzt. Und die Meinungen darüber sind halt wie immer sehr verschieden. Tatsache ist, dass halt derzeit massive juristische Bollwerke aufgefahren werden, um irgendwie Firmen und irgendwie Missbrauch und Verletzungen von Copyright-Regelungen und wie es dann in Amerika so schön heißt, geistiges Eigentum läuft. Und da sind sie ja irgendwie ganz stolz drauf. In Ermangelung einer gewachsenen Kultur meinen sie jetzt, sie hätten die besseren Ideen und dann müssten sie jetzt auch mal alles schützen und mit ihrer Kohle jeden zusammenklagen, der irgendwie vor die Flinte läuft. Und das ist natürlich alles extrem suboptimal, weil erstmal, also wir zum Beispiel, stellen diesen Anspruch auf geistiges Eigentum komplett in Frage. Also ganz im Gegenteil, den gibt es nicht. Es gibt so etwas nicht wie geistiges Eigentum. Es kann nicht sein, dass eine Idee demjenigen gehört, der es irgendwie als wirtschaftliches Gut vertreibt, nicht der es sich gehabt hat, weil es...
Das ist doch eher das Problem. Ich meine, man kann ja durchaus sagen, das gehört mir, gib mir einen Credit. Solange dieser Credit tatsächlich nur eine Nennung ist. Die Idee hat mal Tim gehabt.
Wie willst du sagen, dass eine Idee von mir oder von dir war? Ich meine, was ist die Beweisführung? Deine Ideen basieren vollständig genauso wie meine Ideen und jeder andere Person Ideen auch auf Ideen anderer Leute. Man läuft durch die Gegend, man hört dieses und jedes Wort, das triggert bei einem irgendetwas an. Das ist eine permanente, irgendwie dezentrale Synapsenverschiebung am Start.
Gehen wir doch von Musik aus. Ich meine, okay klar, die Ideen zu den Noten, die sind schon da. Also die Noten sind da und es gibt eine Komposition. Und diese Komposition ist doch zumindest insoweit schützenswert, finde ich, als man sagen könnte, okay, wenn du es spielst, sag wenigstens, wer es zusammen gebastelt hat.
An der Stelle muss man, glaube ich, mal auf einen entscheidenden Unterschied im deutschen Recht eingehen. Und zwar kennt das deutsche Recht zwei verschiedene Sorten Urheberrechte. Nämlich zum einen das Urheberpersönlichkeitsrecht und zum anderen das Urheberverwertungsrecht. Das Urheberpersönlichkeitsrecht ist das Recht, dass es dir das Recht gibt, zu sagen, dass du der Autor davon bist und der dir zum Beispiel auch das Recht gibt, damit Missbrauch mit diesen Dingen zu verhindern, wenn es zum Beispiel gegen dich eingesetzt wird in verleumderischer Form. Das Urheberverwertungsrecht ist das einzige, was übertragbar ist. Das Persönlichkeitsrecht ist nicht übertragbar. Und das beinhaltet tatsächlich die Verwertungsrecht. Das heißt, wer darf das wann auf welchen Datenträger kopieren und warum. Und wer vielleicht nicht. Und nun ist es so, dass die Urheberverwertungsrechte zum größten Teil auch gar nicht mehr bei den Künstlern liegen, sondern bei irgendwelchen Vertriebsgesellschaften. Und die Künstler leider keinen entscheidenden Einfluss mehr haben darauf, wie ihre Kunst verwendet wird, weil sie sie verkauft haben. Und wofür wir plädieren, ist nicht etwa die Abschaffung des Urheberpersönlichkeitsrechts. Weil das ist ja okay, jedermann sollte das Recht haben zu sagen, das war meine Idee. Und es sollte auch jedem verboten sein, den Namen dazu entfernen. Aber die Abschaffung der Urheberverwertungsrechte ist durchaus etwas, über das man nachdenken kann.
Sollte.
Und mittlerweile sind sogar die großen deutschen intellektuellen Tageszeitungen auf diese Diskussion eingestiegen. Und ich denke, es ist mittlerweile ein Kampf von naja, Kultur auf der einen Seite und geistigem Eigentum auf der anderen Seite. Also existiert ein offensichtlicher Widerspruch, ein offensichtlicher Konflikt zwischen Leuten, die sagen, es fördert die Kultur, wenn man etwas verbreiten darf. Anderen Leuten, die sagen, wir dürfen das nicht verbreiten, außer so, wie das vorgesehen ist, weil damit ja Geld verdient wird. Und da kann man ja mal tief in sich gehen und sich fragen, was denn moralisch und wie wertvoller ist, die Kultur oder das Verdienen von Geld. Und ich denke zumindest, die europäische Antwort darauf ist relativ eindeutig. Na, es geht um die Kultur. Es geht darum, dass früher auch Geschichten von Mund zu Mund übertragen werden. Es betrifft ja nicht nur die Musik. Es gibt jetzt mittlerweile zum Beispiel alte Omas, die viel sticken und die das Internet entdeckt haben und die ihre Stickmuster per Internet verbreiten. Und ganz plötzlich stellt sich heraus, dass es eine Stickmusterindustrie gibt, die daran Geld verdient, diese Stickmuster zu verbreiten und die jetzt natürlich aufschreit bei dem Gedanken daran, dass sie jetzt pleite gehen würden. Und da muss man sich fragen, ist tatsächlich die Tatsache, dass ein Stickmuster in Geld verdient wird, der zentrale Punkt unserer Kultur, oder sind es die Stickmuster, und da muss man sagen, die Stickmuster, weil früher wurden die Stickmuster auch von Hand zu Hand übertragen, einfach weitergegeben. Heute gibt es halt die technischen Möglichkeiten, das in einem Stil zu machen, der größer ist als früher, sodass der Bedarf für eine kommerzielle Verteilungsstruktur nicht mehr existiert. Und es kann ja auch passieren, dass solche in Anführungsstrichen verkaufte Kultur verloren geht, wenn zum Beispiel die Firma pleitegeht und die Rechte aufgekauft werden. Es ist einfach weg. Also es kann jederzeit passieren, dass irgendein großer Musikverlag pleitegeht und die Bänder verschüttet gehen und bestimmte Musik einfach nicht mehr da ist. Und es geht ja auch darum, dieses Musikerbe, das wir haben, das kulturelle Erbe insgesamt, sei es Musik, seines Stickmuster, seines Bilder, seines Filme, an zukünftige Generationen weitergeben zu können. Und nicht alles in Intellectual Property Reiz zu ersticken.
Nur das Argument derer, die sagen, sie wollen das Urheberverwertungsrecht behalten, die sind natürlich, dass sie für die Herstellung der Musik, die da irgendwie gespielt wird oder auf eine Platte gepresst wird, Geld ausgeben müssen und dass sie gefälligst dieses Geld wieder haben wollen. Und dass sie darüber hinaus auch noch davon leben können wollen, also sprich einen Gewinn daran erzielen.
Es kann ja keiner verbieten, irgendwie für den reinen Service, die zu dir herzustellen, bunt zu bedrucken, schön das Kabel dazu zu machen, Geld zu nehmen. Ich bin auch bereit, Geld dafür zu zahlen. Da bin ich nicht bereit zu akzeptieren, dass jemand über die bloße Dienstleistung des Vertriebs hinaus Anspruch erhält, etwas zu besitzen, was gar nicht materiell fassbar ist. Das ist ein Aberwitz, der genau das Gegenteil von dem ist, was auf unserer Kultur eigentlich beruht, nämlich, dass wir das benutzen, was die anderthalb früher gemacht haben.
Das Weitergeben von Informationen, das Weitergeben von Wissen und geistiges Eigentum ist die aktive Verhinderung von Fortbildung. Das ist das Speichern von allen Informationen bei wenigen und von wenigen Informationen bei vielen.
Ups, ich hab die Düngemaschine falsch bedient. Nachts ist trocken, 4 bis 1 Grad, morgen bewölkt, nachmittags und abends Regen, bei 6 Bissen, 9 Grad und jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias, guck mich nicht so dämlich an, Klarkow.
Bundestagspräsident Thierse hat die CDU-Haltung zur Ausländerpolitik kritisiert. Mit Blick auf den harten Kurs von Brandenburgs Innenminister Schönbogen fordert er am Abend in Frankfurt oder eine menschliche Auslegung der Ausländergesetze. In der BSE-Krise hat sich die Futtermittelwirtschaft freiwillig zum sofortigen Verzicht auf die Auslieferung und den Export von Tiermehl verpflichtet. Das teilte Landwirtschaftsminister Funke am Abend mit. Ein gesetzliches Verbot der Tiermehlverfütterung wird es vermutlich erst ab dem Wochenende geben. Der US-Milliardär Kirk Kirkhawian hatte eine Schadenzusatzklage in Höhe von 9 Milliarden Dollar gegen Daimler-Kreisler eingereicht. Er wirft Konzernchef Schremf vor, die Kreisler-Aktionäre belogen zu haben. In den USA hat der demokratische Präsidentschaftskandidat Gore offiziell Einspruch gegen das Wahlergebnis in Flauida eingereicht. Sein republikanischer Revade Bush war von der Innenministerin des Bundesstaates zum Sieger erklärt worden.
Und dann in Buchstaben A für Mauro Piccotto mit Komodo.
Oder B für Mojo mit Lady.
Oder C für unseren Paul van Dyck mit Send It Jen und Tell Me Why.
Oder D für Spieler mit Groovejet.
Oder E für Tom Novy mit. Ihr wählt den Radio Dance für 2000.
Nur per SMS an 070 31 81 303.
Und dann A für Mauro Piccotto.
B für Mojo.
C für Paul van Dyck.
D für Spieler.
Oder E für Tom Novy.
Und wer gewinnt, darf zu den German Dance Awards nach Hamburg.
Alles schön klargemacht von www.uboot.com.
Wurzdachs Chaos Radio 56, guten Abend. Wir sind über Peer-To-Peer Netzwerke auf geistiges Eigentum gekommen und stehen geblieben bei dieser Diskussion, die ich hier häufig auch führe, mit Kollegen, die eben tatsächlich mit Musik Geld verdienen.
Wollen wir nicht erstmal das Peer-To-Peer Netzwerk auch hier aufmachen?
Können wir auch aufmachen, klar. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Ja, aber ihr sitzt da ja drauf und hört uns hoffentlich ein wenig zu.
Genau, und ihr könnt auch mit uns telefonieren.
Und wir würden natürlich auch gerne irgendwie eure Beiträge hören. Insbesondere interessiert uns, wie ihr das seht, mit dem geistigen Eigentum. Kann man irgendwie eine Idee besitzen, wie wichtig ist die Kultur im Vergleich dazu? Ist das Recht irgendwie des Einzelnen auf seiner Idee zu bestehen? Irgendwie wichtiger als das Recht der Gemeinschaft.
Glaubt ihr an die Existenz rechtebehafteter Bitmuster?
Genau, und da gibt es eine Telefonnummer, die weißt du auswendig.
Die weißt ich auswendig und die lautet 0331 70 97 110. Was die Kollegen oder Leute, die ich kenne, die mit Musik Geld verdienen, immer wieder in die Waagschale werfen, ist, hey Moment, wir haben Kosten. Also es entstehen einfach Kosten. Es kostet Geld, ein Studio zu mieten, da Aufnahmen zu machen. Es kostet Geld, eine CD zu brennen oder zu pressen. Es kostet Geld, den ganzen Scheiß zu vertreiben. Dieses Geld wollen wir auch wieder reinkriegen. Und plus natürlich einen Gewinn, weil von irgendwas wollen wir leben.
Ja, aber das ist doch, die reden halt von Kosten. Kosten sind nichts besonderes. Wenn man irgendwie ein Geschäft macht, hat man immer Kosten. Man kann sich nicht darüber beklagen, dass irgendetwas teuer ist, um es durchzuführen. Wovon die reden, ist, dass sie jetzt einen definierten Umsatz haben, den sie irgendwie fahren, mit dieser bevorrechteten Stellung. Und wir stellen diese Stellung sozusagen in Frage und sagen irgendwie, warum dürft ihr das tun und warum darf ich das nicht privat machen? So und dann kommen die halt daher, oh Gott, ihr könntet ja unseren Umsatz schmälern und deswegen ist es böse.
Ja, vielleicht sollte man da auch noch ein bisschen weiter aushören, sich mal angucken, woher diese Kosten entkommen. Denn es ist so, dass man seine Kosten nur wieder reinkriegt, wenn man viele Platten verkauft. Und wer verkauft viele Platten, das sind die ganzen Stücke, die in den Top Ten sind, wenn man sich die anguckt. Und naja, also ich finde das nicht besonders qualitativ hochwertig, was da ist. Also handwerklich gut gemacht, aber naja, kein wirklicher kultureller Beitrag. Und diese Sachen verkaufen sich so viel, weil die Firmen, die diese Stücke produzieren, da auch sehr, sehr viel Geld in Marketing steckt. Also müssen auch Leute, die ernsthaft Musik machen, weil sie gerne Musik machen und Musik aus der Liebe zur Musik machen, für ihre Sachen Marketing machen und überhaupt eine Chance zu haben, anzukommen und akzeptiert zu werden.
Also für Madonna und Co. anzustinken.
Genau, wenn das ganze Geld für das Marketing bei den Großen wegfällt, dann brauchen die Kleinen auch kein Marketing mehr zu machen. Vertrieb wird eh deutlich billiger über das Internet. Das ist also keine Ausrede. Marketing, ich denke, das Problem ist auch, dass man Geld dafür bezahlt, eine Meinung zu transportieren. Ich hätte lieber, dass die Meinung sich jemand bildet, der sich auskennt. Also wenn du zum Beispiel was über Musik sagst, die du so hörst, dann glaube ich dir das. Wenn du mir versuchst, deine Musik zu verkaufen, dann bin ich schon ein bisschen Misstraucher. Ich würde gerne das Marketing in Anführungszeichen, also das Bekanntwerden von Bands in den Händen von Leuten sehen, die unabhängig sind und die auch an der Musik interessiert sind, nicht an dem Umsatz, der damit generiert wird. Letzten Endes berichtet es also darauf zusammen, dass man sich die Lebenshaltungskosten leisten können muss und dass man sich vielleicht auch einen entsprechenden Rechner anschaffen muss, auf dem diese ganzen tollen Sachen laufen, mit denen man Musik machen kann. Das sind aber alles endliche Größen. Es gibt einiges an kryptographischen Protokollen, die zum Beispiel sowas gewährleisten, wie das Geld eingesammelt wird. Das heißt, jeder zahlt ein und erst wenn eine bestimmte Summe überschritten wird, kriegt das der Künstler dafür, dass er etwas veröffentlicht. Und wenn diese Summe nicht erreicht wird, kriegen die, die ihr Geld eingelegt haben, das Geld zurück. Ansonsten wird es halt von dem veröffentlicht. Das heißt, er hat sichergestellt, er hat seine Kosten wieder drin. Das ist ja alles, worauf es ankommt. Dass man irgendwie drei Monate braucht oder sechs Monate oder ein Jahr, um wirklich einen guten Song zu machen, dass man diese Zeit bezahlen muss. Das ist eine endliche Summe und die ist nicht abhängig davon, wie viele Leute das hören. Das ist ja der entscheidende Punkt. Und also kann man es auch so machen, dass man nicht abhängig davon ist, wie viele Leute das hören. Und dann hat man nämlich als jemand, der Musik macht, das Interesse, dass das möglichst viele Leute sind.
Und wird sich auch bemühen, ordentliche Musik zu machen.
Genau.
Gehen wir mal ins Telefon. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Also, heute habe ich das richtig mitbekommen. Das geht so ein bisschen um eigene, um geistiges Eigentum und so. Na, jedenfalls, das geht darum. Heute waren wir TV total, ja. Und da hat er angefangen, also ich sage das mal schnell so. Da war so ein Kochter, der hat in einer Sendung mit dem Wort Kakao als Kakao gesprochen. Und da wurde er nominiert. Und bei Stefan Raab ist das dann nur so üblich. Der bringt dann immer irgendwelche CDs raus und verdient dann mit Millionen. Er ist ja wirklich so, er ist ein Steinreich. Und die Sache ist nun halt, dass ich dir zum Beispiel auch mal sage, und dass du vielleicht irgendjemand aufschnappst von den Reaktionen und so. Und der macht dann immer damit Geld.
Das wirstest du dir nachweisführen, dass Kakao auf deinem Mist gewachsen ist.
Ja gut, ich meine, du könntest ja genauso auch damit Geld machen, wenn du irgendwie genauso vorgehen würdest wie Stefan Raab.
Der und seine Leute, die nehmen sich die ganzen guten Gags von anderen Leuten und verdienen damit einen Haufen Schotter.
Wie viele Ideen nimmst du so von Stefan Raab auf? Wie? Na, wie viele Inspirationen hat dir Stefan Raab bereits geliefert?
Also ich gucke das nicht jede Woche. Ich gucke, dass es bloß noch eine Freundin mich drauf gebracht hat. Und damit ich mit ihr auch ein bisschen quatschen kann ordentlich. Aber sonst gucke ich das nicht so oft. Aber der verdient damit einen Haufen Schotter.
Na, das ist ja zunächst einmal nichts Verwerfliches, viel Geld zu verdienen. Ich denke, es ist verwerflich, wenn man dann auch akut Leute daran hindert, auch damit viel Geld zu verdienen.
Naja, die ganzen anderen Leute haben davon auch was verdient. Also ich würde jetzt nicht behaupten, dass ich da Geld verdient habe. Aber wer hätte der jetzt irgendwie da gewonnen und nächste Woche wieder, und die Leute sind darauf scharf, dann hätte er garantiert ein Song rausgebracht oder so und hätte eine Million damit verdient.
Ja gut, einen Teil dieser Millionen hätte er aber auch an den Typen, der KKO gesagt hat, weitergegeben. Das hat er mit Regina Zieh auch so gemacht.
Aber ich denke, der Punkt, den du ansprichst, ist schon ganz wichtiger. Denn wenn man sich mal so die Ideen anguckt, es ist ja nicht so, dass irgendjemand mal irgendetwas komplett von vorne bis hinten durch erfunden hätte, sondern es ist immer so, dass man auf die Arbeit von dem, der davor kommt, aufbaut und nur einen kleinen Teil beisteuert und damit etwas Neues schafft. Und dummerweise ist es halt so, dass man unter unserem System, die verdienen einen Haufen Schotter. Und das ist eigentlich nicht gerecht.
Ja, aber es gibt da nun keinen Switch-Institut, die man nennt, die darüber wacht oder so.
Hm, die darüber wacht. Die worüber wacht.
Na, die darüber wacht, dass da direkt aufgeteilt wird.
Na ja, es gibt da ja so Organisationen wie zum Beispiel die GEMA.
Ja, aber so weit durch wird es auch alt umgangen.
Die Frage war ja auch eher, findest du das sozusagen, also du bist sozusagen ein Anhänger des geistigen Eigentums, du möchtest gerne irgendwie eine Idee haben, und dann möchtest du, dass alle Leute da bei dir dafür bezahlen, dass sie diese Idee verwenden. Aha, und nimmst du das Recht? Also ich meine, wenn du jetzt KKO sagst, wo ist da jetzt die eigentliche Erfindung bei?
Nein, nicht die Erfindung an sich, aber der ist verwendet, um damit Geld zu machen.
Woher weißt du, dass nicht 10 Minuten mal ein KKO gesagt hat? Oder irgendwie 20 Jahre vor dir? Ja, eigentlich müssten alle verdienen. Das ist eben das, wovon wir reden. Eigentlich ist es Quatsch, das auf eine einzelne Person zurückzuführen, weil es nicht geht. Also müssen alle die Möglichkeit haben, das zu tun.
Ja, dann kann man es doch gleich abschaffen, oder nicht?
Vielen Dank, tschau.
031 77 97 110 ist die Nummer hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Hallo, hier ist das Chaosradio.
Ja, hallo, ist das Sven? Ich wollte fragen, aber es gibt doch gewisse Probleme mit dem Patentrecht. Also kehren wir das doch mal um und sagen, dass jetzt mal ein kleiner Erfinder oder eine Bude voller Physiker neuen Laser entwickelt und so weiter. Und wenn die, es mag ja auch sein, dass ihr von vornherein jetzt Urheberrecht und Patentrecht schon in eurer Philosophie unterschieden habt, aber wenn die nicht geschützt werden, dann kommen so Konzerne wie Siemens, das übrigens auch häufig passiert, und könnten dann sofort sich so einen Laser kaufen, den billig nachbauen und zur Hälfte des Preises von denen verkaufen.
Ist ja in Ordnung, wenn das jeder machen kann.
Ja, aber nur Siemens hat dann die Möglichkeit, 20, 30 Ingenieure loszuschicken, die das innerhalb von drei Monaten analysieren.
Ja gut, aber das ist legitim. Aber letzten Endes, nur weil es eine große Firma ist, machen sie sowas nicht gleich besser als andere. Häufig ist es gerade bei innovativen Sachen so, dass eine kleine Firma das besser kann. Also eine große Firma nicht unbedingt ein Vorteil.
Genau, die Entwicklung kann sie besser. Aber wenn dann erst einmal die entscheidende Idee einfach so geklaut werden kann, von einem riesen Konzern, der über andere Wege verfügt, dann gibt es da schon eine große Gefahr. Also, dass kleine Leute oder auch mittelständische Firmen, die im Technologiebereich, wie du ja gerade sagtest, häufig innovativer sind als Großkonzerne, genau diese Ideen dann sehr schnell klauen können und einfach um den Markt für sich zu beanspruchen, ein Viertel oder zur Hälfte des Preises einfach verkaufen.
Wenn ich dir was klaue, also wenn ich deine Stereo-Anlage klaue, dann hast du keine Stereo-Anlage mehr. Richtig?
Das ist eindeutig, ja.
Aber deine Idee hast du danach nach wie vor. Also sowas wie klauen von Ideen zweifle ich schon mal ein wenig an.
Ja, aber wie sieht denn das praktische Problem jetzt?
Also das Problem ist, dass es in der Praxis völlig umgekehrt ist. Es ist ja mitnichten so, dass es hoffenweise kleine Firmen gibt, die sich mit Patenten gut schützen können. Sondern in der Praxis ist es so, dass gerade die großen Firmen, gerade Firmen wie Siemens und IBM, eine solche unglaubliche Menge an Patenten haben. Auf so viele Dinge, dass es ja von vornherein schon mal schwierig ist herauszufinden, ob sie überhaupt etwas patentiert haben, was in deinem Produkt drin steckt. Sodass die Gefahr ist, dass du was erfindest und dann vielleicht ein Patent auf ein Detail hast und aber auch gleich 20 Siemens Patente verletzt hast. Und dann kommt Siemens her und verklagt dich. Und dann bieten sie dir eine außergerichtliche Einigung an, wo drin steht, wir machen irgendwie ein Patent-Trading. Ihr gebt uns euer Patent und wir geben euch unsere Patente. Und dann geht man das mit denen ein und dann sind sie doch in der Lage, das herzustellen, wo sie wohl gegen andere kleinen Firmen halten können.
Ja, okay, aber ich meine, du willst, aber ich meine, welche Motivation sollten dann zum Beispiel Informatiker, Physiker oder solche Leute, irgendwelche innovativen Leute auf irgendeinem Gebiet haben, das Risiko einzugehen, 10 Millionen Mark von irgendeinem Venture-Kapitalist zu nehmen, etwas Neues zu entwickeln? Deine Philosophie mag ja schön und richtig sein, aber da wir im kapitalistischen System leben, muss es ja auch eine Motivation geben, eine Chance zu haben.
Es gibt diese Motivation und im Business Speak nennt man sie First Mover Advantage. Und irgendwie ein Hacker-kompatibel übersetzt heißt, dass der, der die erste Idee hatte, hat auch die erste Implementation und ist der Erste, der Dinge verkauft, und derjenige, der bewiesen hat, dass er wirklich verstanden hat. Das ist kein Problem damit, wenn dann irgendwie ein Jahr später ein Wettbewerb einsetzt und man beweisen muss, dass man seine Sache nicht nur einmal gut gemacht hat, sondern auch kontinuierlich gut macht.
Okay, aber glaubst du denn, dass im langfristigen Wettbewerb so kleine Buden, wenn sie gar keine Patente mehr anmelden, überhaupt eine Chance haben gegen große Konzerne?
Ich glaube, dass sie keine Chance haben, solange es Patente gibt. Ich glaube, dass man Patente abschaffen muss, damit kleine Firmen eine Chance gegen große Firmen haben.
Du gehst ja davon aus, dass es heute so wäre, dass irgendwie man macht eine kleine Firma, und dann meldet man zehn Patente an, und dann ist man sicher. Die Realität ist genau andersrum. Erstens können sich kleine Firmen diese Patente fast überhaupt nicht leisten, weil überhaupt eins anzumelden, ist ein sehr zeitaufwändiger, personalaufwändiger, juristischer Aufwand. Das kreuzet richtig viel Geld und Zeit. Und darüber hinaus schützt sich das, weil, wie wir das ja eben schon dargestellt haben, ist bei den meisten technologischen Bereichen heutzutage so, ist das sowieso, irgendeine Firma entweder tatsächlich ein entsprechendes Patent hat, oder zumindest erstmal behauptet, dass sie ein solches haben und dann sofort ihre Juramaschinerie auf dich drauf werfen und dann sagen wir mal, wie ein kleiner Informatiker sich gegen die juristische Abteilung von IBM zu wehr setzen soll. Das ist real nicht möglich. Und genau das ist das, was heute stattfindet. Es ist nicht so, dass die geschützt werden, sondern geschützt werden ausschließlich die, die das Geld haben, diese Maschine überhaupt noch in Bewegung zu halten und da den Überblick zu halten.
Naja, okay, das ist mir bekannt. Also dann wäre dein Argument also, dass eigentlich meine Idee ganz gut ist, aber da in der Praxis das alles immer umgedreht wird, ist daher sinnvoller, Patente abzuschaffen. Also auch damit die Chancen größer...
Dann hat man diesen ganzen Streit nicht. Und jeder macht einfach das am besten, was er kann. Und wenn ein Produkt gut ist, dann wird es auch gekauft. Nur weil jetzt jemand mal behauptet und zu dem Zeitpunkt auch das Geld gehabt hat, zu behaupten, er hätte diese Idee gehabt. Deswegen irgendwie wie ein Füllhorn die ganze Kohle der eigenen Arbeit da reinfließen zu lassen, halte ich für anmaßend. Und dieses Argument mit unsere Akademiker werden ja überhaupt nicht mehr bezahlt. Und die haben ja überhaupt keine Basis mehr. Die würden ja so tun, als würde Forschung schon immer nur auf diesem Modell betrieben worden sein. Das ist auch blödsinn. Es wird sehr viel geforscht außerhalb von solchen Sachen. Die meisten Forschungsabteilungen sind ohnehin mittlerweile bei großen Firmen.
Also ich meine, gerade in der Physik kann ich es ein bisschen beurteilen. Und da ist es eigentlich relativ mau. Also ich meine, im Vergleich zu den USA gibt es hier wenig privatenwirtschaftliches, ich glaube, rein umsatzmäßig. Also Siemens zum Beispiel stellt auch, hat doch schon ewig keine Physiker mehr eingestellt.
Aber das sind doch große Firmen in den USA, die diese Forschung machen. Das ist irgendwie dann keine Ahnung, von wem man sich als Physiker beschäftigen lassen kann, von Lockheed oder von IBM oder von wem auch immer. Das sind ja keine kleinen mittelständischen Unternehmen.
Aber okay, dann mein Punkt ist damit auch, glaube ich, abgehandelt.
Prima, danke schön.
Danke für deinen Anruf, ciao. Wenn ihr auch anrufen wollt, dann macht das bitte unter 033 177 97 110. Hallo, Chaosradio hier.
Moin Moin, ich bin Adam. Ja, meine Idee dazu ist, wenn man jetzt ja die Sache wieder umdreht und sagt, es gibt ja große Firmen, die entwickeln, sagen wir, nehmen wir mal an das 3-Liter-Auto, wenn man das jetzt wieder auf Umweltschutz beziehen würde. Und die entwickeln, sagen wir, einen Motor, der sehr sparsam ist. Und stellen fest, wenn wir das Ding bauen würden, würden andere Industrien damit Mittenbach runtergehen, setzen da ein Patent drauf, sperren das. Und wenn jetzt eine andere Firma dieses einfach benutzen könnte, dieses Auto bauen, es würde einen Absatzmarkt finden, denke ich jetzt, in Deutschland besonders, dann wäre das doch ideal und würde somit auch wieder einen guten Zweck erfüllen.
Ich denke, das ist auch ein sehr wichtiges Argument, dass Patente in keinster Weise fair sind, sondern auch dazu eingesetzt werden, bestimmte Technologien um 20 Jahre zu verzögern. Man stelle sich nur mal vor, wie das gewesen wäre, wenn damals der erste Mensch, der auf die Idee gekommen ist, Brot zu backen, das patentiert hätte, und trotz gesagt hätte, ich sage euch das jetzt nicht, eine ganze Menschheit hätte 20 Jahre gehungert. Das mag vielleicht wie ein krasser Vergleich klingen, aber wenn man an so Sachen wie AIDS usw. usf. denkt, das ist ein ähnliches Potenzial, was da dahinter steckt.
Es geht ja nicht nur um die Besitzbarkeit von Ideen. Es gibt ja komische Länder in Nordamerika, wo inzwischen alles besitzbar ist. Also nicht nur die Ideen, die du hörst, auch deine Gene oder die Gene von irgendeiner zufälligen Kreuzung, die entstanden ist, weil sich in deinem Kellernick Kakerlaken mit einer Bienen gekreuzt hat. Das kannst du patentieren lassen, was aberwitzig ist.
Jaja, man ist die alte amerikanische Kultur des Landbesitzers. Ich bin jetzt hier und weil ich jetzt hier bin, gehört mir das. Jaja, Eigentum ist da sozusagen die Kultur.
Genau.
Aber andererseits ist es ja auch wieder gefährlich, wenn ja risikobehaftete Sachen, zum Beispiel, wie irgendwelche wilden Genmutationen, auf einmal von jedem benutzt werden können.
Ich denke, da sollte an einer anderen Stelle reguliert werden. Man kann ja durchaus bestimmte Genexperimente einfach verbieten, wie das in Deutschland der Fall ist, wo nicht mit menschlichen Embryonen experimentiert werden darf. Das ist ja auch völlig gerechtfertigt. Aber nichtsdestotritt muss das Wissen, dass darüber angesammelt werden, weitergetragen werden. Man denke zum Beispiel nur daran, welche Experimente gemacht wurden, bei denen sich herausgestellt hat, dass das gefährlich ist. Das sollte man auf jeden Fall nicht noch mal machen, weil es gerade so gut gegangen ist. Oder man denke daran, dass an bestimmten Orten zum Beispiel Giftmüll vergraben ist oder Atommüll und wie wenige Leute darüber wissen. Und einfach in dem Moment, wo man solches Wissen über die Lage der Welt versucht einzuschränken, schafft man auch eine Gefahr für die nachkommenden Generationen.
Also Informationen müssen frei sein.
Ich denke man muss da auch inhaltlich unterscheiden. Also wenn man jetzt gerade Daten irgendwo im Internet überträgt, sind das ja im Prinzip nur Eins und Nullen. Woher der Rechner kann da also nicht den Inhalt unterscheiden. Das kann ja nur wieder ein Mensch. Und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so Sachen nimmt, wie Musik, da können ja dann die Leute vom Inhalt nur unterscheiden, was ist das für ein Stück und wem gehört das. Und wenn ich das jetzt einfach vervielfaltige, ohne dass der andere da dran, also der Urheber da dran verdient, also ohne dass die ganze Industrie wieder dran hängt, verdient, da hängen ja dann auch in der Industrie wieder Leute dran, die daran verdienen, dann müsste man das insofern einschränken, bei irgendwelchen inhaltlichen Sachen, die gefährlich sein könnten, müsste man das ja dann auch irgendwie unterbinden.
Gibt es denn Informationen, die gefährlich sind?
Wenn man jetzt andererseits Wissen nimmt, was in Jahrhunderten schon entwickelt wurde und darüber erforscht wurde, worauf man im Prinzip die ganze Bildung und die Weiterentwicklung aufbaut, das muss natürlich frei sein. Deswegen muss man da irgendwie inhaltlich...
Aber wer soll das entscheiden können? Viele Sachen, die für uns heute selbstverständlich sind, sind vielleicht für Leute in tausend Jahren völlig neu und ungewohnt. Also vielleicht fragen sie sich irgendwann mal, warum überall vergraben sind und was diese dreieckigen Warnschilder mit den drei Propellerflügeln zu bedeuten haben. Und ich denke, man muss schon dafür sorgen, dass unsere gesamte Kultur, also alles, was heutzutage existiert, an die nachfolgenden Generationen weitergetragen werden kann, damit die verstehen, wie bestimmte geschichtliche Prozesse entstanden sind. Also zum Beispiel über das dritte bis achte Jahrhundert unserer europäischen Geschichte ist unglaublich wenig bekannt, weil es da unglaublich wenig Überlieferungen gibt. Und wir leben momentan in einem Zeitalter, in dem ziemlich viel digital passiert. Und wo leider digitale Datenträger allerhöchstens 10 Jahre halten und dann einfach kaputt sind. Und wir könnten irgendwie das dunkle Zeitalter der Digitalgesellschaft werden, weil unsere Daten nicht mehr da sind, weil wir zu dumm waren, unsere Daten rechtzeitig an einen anderen Ort zu kopieren.
Ja und wenn die Daten auch an zu wenig Orten liegen. Du hast ja selber gerade das richtigen Daten, die vielleicht Krebs heilen, und wenn die nix sind, dann sind sie halt einfach.
Gar nicht.
Die Bits sind alle gleich, ob du jetzt irgendwie 8-Bit Musik kopierst, oder 8-Bit beliebige Daten, oder 8-Bit Müll, oder 8-Bit Neonazi-Propaganda. Das ist alles dasselbe einfach irgendwie. Da gibt es keine Filter und keine Unterschiede. Das sind alles nur Informationen.
Es gibt auch keine guten Daten und keine bösen Daten. Es gibt einfach nur Daten.
Das war das Chaosradio 56 und wir versuchen über geistiges Eigentum zu reden und die Nummer, unter der ihr mitreden könnt ist die 0331 70 97 110. Bitte habt ein bisschen Geduld, wenn ihr in der Leitung hängt. Guten Abend.
Ich würde mal ganz fragen, was denn aus diesen Software-Patenten geworden ist. Es gab ja mal riesige Aufregung, weil da irgendeine britische Firma Patente auf Überlinks erhoben hat oder so weiter.
Ich würde die Stelle kommen.
Ja, das ist, ähm, also da gab es eigentlich mehrere parallele Entwicklungen. Das eine ist das Akute, weswegen alle auf diese Software-Patente aufmerksam geworden sind. Und zwar gab es auf Initiative der USA in Europa einen Regelungsentwurf, der vorsah, dass der Paragraph, der die Patentierbarkeit von Software an sich verbietet, abgeschafft werden soll. Und nur ist natürlich unklar, was Software an sich ist, deshalb ist das alles ein bisschen schwammig. Auf jeden Fall wurde das nach lautstarken offiziellen Prozess abgeschmettert. Das heißt, Software an sich ist nach wie vor nicht patentierbar. Das Problem dabei ist, dass es bereits in Deutschland Europas hafte Patente gibt. Und dass Firmen wie zum Beispiel Siemens und IBM und einige andere auch schon heftig dabei sind, Software zu patentieren. Über eine Hintertür, und zwar kann man ja eigentlich keine mathematischen Verfahren patentieren. Es heißt dann also immer nicht irgendwie Patent für multidimensionale B-Trees, sondern es heißt Patent für multidimensionale B-Trees zur Speicherung von Daten auf Rechnersystemen mit CPU, Festplatte und RAM. Mit anderen Worten, eine Umschreibung dafür, dass das Ganze auf einem Computer stattfindet. Und das reicht aus, damit es sich nicht mehr um eine Entdeckung, sondern um eine technische Erfindung. Also de facto haben wir bereits Software-Patente und es ist zwar gut und schön, dass da jetzt gewonnen wurde gegen die EU, aber das ist mehr oder weniger entscheidend, vielleicht was da geführt wird.
Zu dem Punkt kann ich auch noch anmerken, irgendwie, wenn ihr euch für das Thema interessiert und euren Centrum ablassen wollt, dann gibt es da eine ganz schöne Petition von einer Webseite, die nennt sich petition.eurolinux.org und die Liste der Supporter ist irgendwie relativ groß, also alles dabei, was in der Open Software, im Open Source Community Rang und Namen hat, unterstützen das bei Sponsors unten. Und da könnt ihr euren Namen hinsetzen und das wird dann der Europäischen Kommission oder Parlament übergeben und da steht drin, dass ihr gegen Software-Patent ist. Und man kann sich da auch irgendwie mit richtigen Ab- und Design-Truppen die Sammelstelle für die Leute zu sein, die dagegen sind.
Kleine Frage noch, seid ihr im Chat?
Nein, wir sind nicht online, weil der L-Server mal wieder zu richtig ist.
Da kommt dauernd das Geschrei hoch, dass ihr die Cam drehen sollt, dass man auf euch mal sieht.
Oh, Sie sehen heute Nacht. Das ist ja so richtig unerfreulich.
Was wollt ihr denn sehen? Was willst du denn sehen?
Hättest du nicht früher sagen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wirklich sehen wollt.
Lieber als das, was wir vorher gesehen haben.
So, hallo, nicht so viel winken, das gibt Schlieren auf dem JPEG.
Das ist doch wohl nicht wahr, das Ding wird ja wohl eine schnelle Belichtungszeit haben.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Sieht das alles nicht so schlimm, also die Schlieren, die da vorher drauf fallen, jetzt ist das schon eine...
Eine Axel-Communication-Kamera, sieht ziemlich cool aus.
Du warst gerade...
Nein, nicht so reden... .in die Tastatur gekickt.
Wir danken jetzt erstmal für deinen Anruf.
Ich rette mal die Tastatur.
Und was ich jetzt eigentlich sage, ist, dass dieser Kamera auch in Nios läuft.
Das Chaosradio 56 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Nummer. Und wer ist dran? Ja, mach mal deinen Radio leiser bitte. Dass man's immer noch erklären muss.
Wir sind noch mal zurückkommen auf das Erchen des Geissigen Einzugs, was wohl angesprochen wurde. Das war die kleine nette Geschichte aus der Datenschleuder für Freie und Querdenker. Und zwar die Strickomis, die da ihre Stricknüsse untereinander ausgetauscht haben. Und das Verheerende und das Grafe, die Wirkung, die dadurch entstehen, zum Beispiel, dass den Omnis dann schon den Newsgroup geschlossen wurde.
Findest du nicht gut?
Nee, das ist halt nicht das Tolle daran.
Weil immer es durch und nicht kommuniziert.
Genau, dass der Informationsschluss gestoppt wird oder verboten wird. Wie zum Beispiel im Vorhinein auch mit dem AIDS. Zum Beispiel, wie Technik entwickelt wird, die man dann teilen kann oder so. Und die darf man dann halt nicht vertrieben, oder so. Weil irgendwann jemand kommt und ein Patent aufhört, Menschen darüber nach.
Erzählst du den Leuten davon? Wie bitte? Erzählst du den Leuten davon? Redest du mit anderen darüber?
Ja, ich versuche mit anderen darüber zu reden. Und habe auch schon mit einigen Erfolg gehabt. Und ja, ich finde es auch gut, dass es so etwas wie die Datenschäden gibt. Der CCC leistet da ganz große Arbeit, muss ich sagen. Das ist meine Meinung.
Allerdings, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Es wird nicht nur einfach der Informationsaustausch verändern, es wird auch aktiv wirklich Zensur betrieben. Kann man fast schon sagen, wenn man den Leuten einfach den Kommunikationskanal weg. Das ist, also.
Dr. Monson, platz deine Hände an der Hand!
Ja, wir reden über Geburtstagstechniken, weil ist ja die Geburtstagscars-Radiosendung heute.
Ja, wir haben ja viel über geistiges Eigentum geredet und wenn man so den Leuten, die da irgendwie so ein bisschen Angst vor einer Änderung der aktuellen Regelung, die da Angst äußern, hört man häufig auch raus, so die fehlende Vision für ein anderes Modell. Man ist halt einfach so sehr daran gewöhnt, in einen Laden zu gehen und etwas zu kaufen, was vorbereitet wurde, also einfach so wie es derzeit ist, das ist eben drin in den Köpfen. Aber es gibt durchaus Alternativen, die sich entwickeln. Ein richtig gutes Micropayment gibt es leider noch nicht etabliert, das wird auch irgendwie kräftig verhindert von die Arbeiten der Leute dran.
Da kann ich vielleicht nachher noch Wort zu sagen.
Und so eine ganz einfache Sache, die auch tatsächlich diese Geschenkkultur des Internet unterstreicht, ist zum Beispiel was Amazon anbietet. Amazon ist der große Buch und sonstige Sachen, Händler im Internet, eine Website, die bemerkenswert gut funktioniert. Und wo man nicht nur selber was kaufen kann, sondern man kann dort auch eine Wunschliste erstellen. Das heißt, man kann diverse Produkte in der Datenbank markieren, als die will ich gerne haben, aber ich kann sie mir nicht kaufen. Und wenn dieser Mensch jetzt aber irgendetwas anderes tut, zum Beispiel Software schreiben oder sonst irgendwelche Dienstleistungen machen, Bücher schreiben oder so, dann können Leute, die eben sein Werk genossen haben, freiwillig entscheiden, ihm aus seiner Wunschliste einfach etwas zu kaufen.
Und das wird auch getan.
Und das ist eine sehr schöne Methode. Eine, so, da wird es noch sehr viel mehr geben, aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine, die schon mal klar zeigt, dass das traditionelle Verkau-Pitalismus-Modell, wie wir es bisher gekannt haben, nicht unbedingt jetzt der Maßstab für alles das, was da kommt sein muss. Auch das Internet hat gezeigt, dass eigentlich so ziemlich alles ganz anders geht, als man das irgendwie noch vor Kurzem gemacht hat. Da fällt man ja fast nichts ein, wo das nicht irgendeine Auswirkung gehabt hat, von halt Business bis hin zu Politik. Alle drehen so ein bisschen am Rad, weil sie es halt nicht verstehen. Aber dass das auch alles nichts bedrohliches ist, sondern das ist im Wesentlichen eine positive Tendenz. Man muss bloß darauf achten, dass man jetzt nicht so viel Angst hat, man neophobe wird und irgendwie nur Bedrohungen sieht und irgendwie Neonazi-Horden und so, sondern dass man einfach sich eine bestimmte Medienkompetenz zulegt, mit diesem Medium auch umzugehen und selber zu bewerten und für sich selber zu denken, was denn nun gut und richtig ist. Ich fange ja nicht gleich an, irgendwelche Häuser abzubrennen, nur weil ich sie seitendese. Wer das liest, der hat ohnehin eine Neigung, die wahrscheinlich aus seinem sozialen Umfeld im Wesentlichen heraus entsteht und seinen persönlichen Verhältnissen auf diesem Planeten. Aber nicht, weil er jetzt eine Information findet. Ich finde auch irgendwie von links- und rechtsradikalen immer mal wieder irgendwelche Flyer auf dem Boden. Aber da sterbe ich ja auch nicht gleich dran. Man muss halt da sich seine eigene Kompetenz entwickeln und andere Modelle akzeptieren.
Aber diese Kompetenz zu entwickeln, beliegen uns Politiker, die dann darüber befinden, Regulierungen einzuführen. Diese Kompetenz belegen wir sonst nicht zu.
Ja, das ist derzeit einfach ein Kampf, der geführt werden muss. Und da sind wir ja auch dabei.
So, mit Schimmel jetzt gerade. Klack, so wir gehen nach Hause, das war's, tschüss.
Hätten wir dich noch mal auf das Öl überblenden können?
Ja, ich hatte auch gehofft, dass er ein bisschen g'nadert. Dann mach ich noch mal ein bisschen. Das geht nicht, das ist einfach zu heftig. Wo waren wir denn?
Wo waren wir denn?
0331 77 97 110, da könnt ihr übrigens mit dem Chaosradio telefonieren.
Wir waren auf dem Weg auf ein neues Kulturverständnis, da waren wir angekommen.
Ja, Andreas hat das Micro-Payment-Protokolle genannt.
Ja, genau. Und zwar, was man im Zusammenhang mit Peer-To-Peer Networks auf jeden Fall noch erwähnen muss, ist MojoNation. MojoNation ist ein relativ cleverer Service, der im Prinzip auf ein Peer-To-Peer-Micro-Payment aufgebaut ist. Das heißt, es gibt eine Bank, da kann man Tokens entnehmen und Tokens auch wieder einzahlen. Und was man da macht, ist Plattenplatz bereitstellen, genau wie Napster. Nur, dass man für die Dienstleistung, dass jemand was von einem downloadet, von dem anderen Micro-Payment-Tokens bekommt. Wenn man irgendwo was downloadet, muss man welche bezahlen. Das heißt, es handelt sich um ein geschlossenes ökonomisches System. Ich mache meine Platte auf, Leute laden da Daten ab, ich bekomme da Geld dafür und kann dann dieses Geld ausgeben, um dafür neue Songs zu kaufen.
Moment, dafür, dass sie Daten abladen bei mir, kriege ich was von denen?
Ja, genau. Und dafür, dass Leute was downloaden, kriegst du auch was.
Was für Daten?
Beliebige Daten. MojoNation hat ein Splitting-System eingebaut, das heißt, wenn du etwas in dieses System uploadest, dann wird das in acht Teile aufgeteilt und du brauchst mindestens vier von diesen acht Teilen.
Wir haben wieder Musik und das führt zu Gefuchtel, lass dich nicht stören.
Okay, mindestens vier von diesen acht Teilen, ich brauche aus meinem einen Teil acht, lade die auf acht verschiedene Server hoch. Und wenn man etwas downloaden will, muss man sich das von mindestens vier verschiedenen Servern holen. Und wenn man nicht mindestens vier Teile hat, kann man die Daten auch nicht ansehen, was sie sind. Das heißt, ich als Serverbetreiber tue nichts anderes als Plattenplatz zu vermieten. Und ich weiß nicht, was für Daten da abgelegt werden. Weil ich betrage ja bloß eine Transportdienstleistung. Für den Inhalt der Daten ist ja immer jemand anders verantwortlich.
Wo kriege ich denn das erste Geld her?
Das kannst du zum Beispiel bei irgendjemanden tauschen. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel sehr, sehr viel Plattenplatz habe und mehr Mojos habe, als ich downloaden möchte, dann kann ich dir ja gegen Geld Mojos verkaufen. Und davon kann ich mir Brötchen kaufen.
Kann ich mir denn Andres Mojos auch kaufen?
Ja, und zwar gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder du gehst zu der Mojo Zentralbank, wo du dann zu einem bestimmten Betrag Mojos erwerben kannst. Das sind die auch die, die die Token-Transaktion übernehmen. Oder die andere Möglichkeit ist, dass dir Mojos jemand verkauft. Das heißt sozusagen das Bootstrapping, das initiale Aufbau des Mechanismus, passiert darüber, dass man Zentral Mojos kauft. Oder vielleicht auch erstmal Plattenplatz bereitstellt, wenn man keinen Plattenplatz hat, weil man Plattenplatz hat und eine IP-Anbindung hat, kann man ja eine Platte aufmachen und damit Geld verdienen, wenn man kein Geld überweisen möchte oder kann.
Das heißt, ich nehme einfach von meinen 10 GB zwei Stück und spendiere die denen.
Genau, die spendierst du nicht denen, sondern die spendierst du dem kollektiven Kulturspeicher.
Und wie werden die auf mich aufmerksam? Also wie wird der kollektive Kulturspeicher auf mich aufmerksam, sodass dann irgendwer irgendwann seine Daten da lagert und mir irgendwie dafür den ein oder anderen Mojo überweist?
Dafür gibt es sogenannte Tracking-Server, die sind auch verteilt. Du kannst also bei dir auch so einen Tracking-Server einschalten. Das sind Suchmaschinen. Und du kriegst natürlich auch Geld dafür, dass Leute bei dir Suchanfragen machen. Und ja, wo diese Trecker herkommen, das steht in einem Meta-Trecker. Und der Meta-Trecker ist wiederum verteilt. Also das funktioniert so, wie man ihn immer seine Nachbarn kennt. Nur, dass nicht sämtlicher Verkehr über diese Links läuft, sondern das nur das sehr, sehr minimale Austauschen.
Das Wer-ist-in-Service über diese Links macht.
Ja, das ist selbstgemachte Musik, nicht von uns, aber wurde uns auf den Weg mitgegeben.
Ich bin kein Dope MC, ich wollte es auch nie sein, ich kicke lieber meinen Rhyme, denn ein Zeilen verweilen Töne, die könnt ihr nicht hören. Merkt nur, wie sie eure Ohren betören, weil lasst euch nicht stören von mir und meiner Wiss. Und dann kommst du, du also los, mach'n Schuh, ich zieh noch einen Kopf an meiner Fuh. Bodegas auf der Jagd, aber waag es nicht, gegen uns die Faust zu erhebeln, du wirst es nicht überleben. Wenn ich dich morgens seh, muss ich mich übergeben. Bodegas, wir sind krass, pass auf, du sparst, wir von uns gehast, was verfasst. Bodegas, wir sind krass, pass auf, du sparst, wir von uns geächtet, wird von jedem gehasst. Wenn du denkst, dass du Bodegas bist, wirst du gedisst und merkst, dass es nicht so ist. Wir werden dir sagen, Bodegas ist nach dem Battle der Fahrer deines gleichen Wagen. Bodegas ist hart wie Ficken im Smart. Wir haben 30 Holes am Start. Bonetta, ich werd heiter. Bodegas, wir sind krass, pass auf, du Spaß. Wer nicht mit uns unten ist, hat was verpasst. Bodegas, wir sind krass, pass auf, du Spaß. Wer von uns geächtet wird von jedem gehasst. Das ist Strophe drei und alle sind dabei. Au wo, au wei, Bodegas auf der Tour und von Abarmen keine Spur. So pass auf, sonst geht's dir schlecht. In unserer Bäche regiert unser Recht. Geschwächt von unseren Flows kriegst du weg vom Geschehen, worauf wir uns in neue Tüte drehen. Du wirst sehen, gegen uns kannst du nicht bestehen. Da hilft kein Betteln und kein Flehen. Bodegas gesucht wegen tausend Vergehen. Keiner kann ahnen oder verstehen. Wir haben Bill Gates getötet und sein Monopol an uns gerissen. Auf Billys Grab wird geschissen. Wir wollen ihn nicht, damit sich alle Developer von ihm abwenden. Bodegas, wir sind krass, pass auf, du Spaßst. Wer nicht mit uns unten ist, hat was verpasst. Bodegas, wir sind krass, pass auf, du Spaßst. Wer von uns geächtet, wird von jedem gehasst.
Tja, das war die neue Platte der absoluten Beginner. Wer war das, Tim?
Offensichtlich Bodegas.
Ah, offensichtlich, ja stimmt. Wie bin ich auch, ich bin auch blöd, so was zu fragen. Entschuldigt bitte. Herrlich, herrlich, herrlich, herrlich, herrlich, herrlich.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Das Wetter, nachts meist trocken, bei 4 bis 1 Grad am Tag, bewölbt nachmittags und abends Regen bei 6 bis 9 Grad und die Melden mit Matthias.
Romantik. Bundestagspräsident Thierse hat jetzt die Urhaltung zur Ausländerpolitik kritisiert. Mit Blick auf den harten Kurs von Brandenburgs Innenminister Schönbunferde, der am Abend in Frankfurt-Oder eine menschliche Auslegung der Ausländergesetze. In der BSE-Krise hat sich die Futtermittelwirtschaft freiwillig zum sofortigen Verzicht auf die Auslieferung und den Export von Tiermehl verpflichtet. Das deutet Anwortschaftsminister Funke am Abend mit. Ein gesetzliches Verbot der Tiermittelverfütterung wird es vermutlich erst ab dem Wochenende geben. In Rumänien hat die Regierungskoalition bei den Präsidenten und Parlamentswahlen eine schwere Niederlage erlitten. Zwei der fünf bürgerlichen Parteien schafft nicht mehr den Sprung über die 5-%-Hürde.
Fritz sagt, beteiligt euch an den German Dancing World und gewinnt eine Reise für zwei genau da.
Fällt die Nummer 070-31-81-303.
Und dann den Buchstaben A für Mauro Picotto mit Komodo.
Oder B für Mojo mit Lady.
Oder C für unseren Paul-Fan-Dus mit Zettelchen und Tell Me Why.
Oder D für Spieler mit Groovejet.
Oder E für Tom Novy mit Now or Never. Ihr wählt den Radio Dance new 2000.
Nur per SMS an 070-31-81-303.
Und dann A für Mauro Picotto.
B für Mojo.
C für Paul-Fan-Dus.
D für Spieler.
Oder E für Tom Novy.
Und wer gewinnt?
Alles schön klar gemacht von www.uboos.com.
Soll ich den Schmerz mal beenden hier?
Ah ja, bitte den Schmerz beenden.
Also es ist ja wirklich unglaublich. Tim hat die Tastatur gekillt mit der Club-Marte, mit Ascht und sein Paar, nee, Zink-Bit. Und ich hoffe, wir bleiben weiter uns in Ruhe verschoben.
Ich hab da ja ein Problem mit meinem Zink-Bit, aber... So, jetzt nehme ich einen MojoNation-Teil, biete da meinen Plattenplatz zu Pfeil, da legt jemand sein Zeugs ab, ich krieg da für Mojos. Was hab ich davon? Also ich musste doch irgendwo von dem Computer aufbezahlen. Das heißt, ich muss in irgendeiner Form auch einen Gewinn machen, oder nicht?
Ja, du kannst dann natürlich mit deinen Mojos hingehen und kannst Leuten, sind bei Leuten auch was downloaden. Wenn du irgendwie ein bestimmtes Musikstück suchst, musst du das ja irgendwo finden, das muss irgendwo liegen. Das heißt, du brauchst eine Suchmaschine, du kannst mit Mojos bezahlen. Du brauchst den Download, den kannst du mit Mojos bezahlen und so weiter und so fort. Und das werden sie sicherlich auch noch andere Dienstleistungen dann auf das Mojo aufbauen. Das ganze Protokoll ist so designt, dass die gesamte Bezahlung und die Verschlüsselung, die da auch eingebaut ist und die Authentifizierung als unterste Protokollschicht stattfindet. Das heißt, die ganzen Dienstleistungen wie Suchmaschinen, Falldownloads sind da oben drauf aufgebaut und man kann da auch beliebige andere Sachen drauf aufbauen. Es wäre also zum Beispiel vorstellbar, dass du deinen Mail-Account mit Mojos bezahlst. Du hast halt irgendwo einen Account und regelmäßig wirfst du Mojos ein und kriegst dafür Mail.
Verzinsung ist da nicht vorgesehen. Also das heißt Spekulation.
Naja, zumindest nicht bankseitig. Aber es ist natürlich durchaus möglich, dass wir untereinander einen Vertrag machen. Ich überweis dir heute 1000 Mojos und du überweist mir morgen 2000 Mojos. Da hindert mich ja keiner dran. Also im Prinzip ja.
MojoNation. Wir sind übrigens das ChaosRadio 56, reden über Peer-To-Peer-Systeme und geistiges Eigentum und im Moment über MojoNation. Der Weisheit letzter Schluss scheint mir das aber nicht zu sein, weil du hast ein neues Wirtschaftssystem, also was sich da aufbaut, indem du mit den Mojos zahlst, aber letztlich läuft doch MojoNation genauso Gefahr, unter der Spekulation zu leiden, wie das normale Leben auch darunter leidet. Ich denke, ich gehe davon aus, dass die Wurzel allen übelst, oder zumindest eine der größeren Wurzeln allen übelst, Spekulation ist, insbesondere mit Grundbesitz.
Das ist sicherlich wahr und nur ist es zum Glück so, dass MojoNation zwar nach wie vor ein Markt ist, aber sehr gute Voraussetzungen als Markt mitbringt. Es gibt sehr, sehr viele Marktteilnehmer, nämlich jeder, der daran teilnehmen kann, sowohl die Dienstleistung erbringen, als auch die Dienstleistung in Anspruch nehmen. Das heißt, dass es keine Monopolbildung gibt oder keine Oligopole. Der zweite Punkt ist, dass die Kommunikation zwischen den Teilnehmern sehr, sehr schnell ist dank Internet. Das heißt, dass sich die Informationen über die Beschaffenheit des Marktes sehr, sehr schnell ausbreiten. Das ist ja in der Markttheorie sehr, sehr wichtig, weil der ideale Markt ein Markt ist, in dem die Information sich unendlich schnell ausbreitet. Wir sind heutzutage bei 250 Millisekunden einmal um den Globus. Das ist schon ziemlich dicht dran. Zum Dritten ist es auch völlig egal, wo eine Dienstleistung erbracht wird. Vielleicht mag es ein bisschen billiger sein, wenn ich einen Server um die Ecke nehme und einen weiter weg. Das ist ein bisschen teurer, aber die Unterschiede sind nicht so gravierend. Das heißt auch, dass das Marktgleichgewicht sehr, sehr leicht hergestellt werden kann, weil es wenig regionaler Abhängigkeiten gibt.
Und ist es sensierbar oder kontrollierbar oder regulierbar? Einfach der Verlust der Information selbst, was gerade im normalen Leben auch passiert. Bestimmte Marktinformationen bleiben mir eine bestimmte Zeit lang vorenthalten, sodass ich nicht darauf reagieren kann.
Das liegt aber zum Beispiel bei der Börse daran, dass es ein Copyright auf diese Daten gibt und dass du diese Daten nur dann rechtzeitig erhältst, wenn du einen Vertrag unterschreibst, wo drin steht, dass du sie nicht weitergibst. Oder nur bestimmten Kunden weitergibst gegen die Zahlung. Aber MojoNation ist ja schon ein Beispiel dafür, dass sich Protokolle schaffen lassen, mit denen man Informationsaustausch nicht verhindern kann. Wenn man sich die Kommunikation zwischen zwei MojoNation-Notes anguckt, Client und Server sind ja identisch in der Kommunikationsweise, dann wird man ausschließlich verschlüsselte Pakete zwischen Rechnern sehen. Dann wird man nicht ansehen können, was da drin steckt. Und es lässt sich selbst mit beliebig vielen Firewalls immer ein wenig liegen, weil man muss ja schließlich auch irgendwie an die Webseiten kommen. Ein sehr beliebter Trick, um durch eine missliebige Firewall von innen nach außen zu kommen, ist sich auf den Proxy zu connecten und eine Verbindung auf Port 443 anzufragen, auf einen Zielrost. Und das ist eine harte TPS-Verbindung, also ist sie verschlüsselt, also kann der Proxy sie nicht interpretieren, also reicht er sie einfach durch. Und der kann natürlich nicht unterscheiden, ob ich jetzt auf dieser verschlüsselten Verbindung den Server am anderen Ende wirklich nach einer Webseite frage, oder ob ich da einen IP-Tunnel mit ihm drüber spreche, um meine Daten irgendwo an einen anderen Ort zu kriegen, ohne dass der Rechner dazwischen irgendetwas mitbekommt. Das heißt, Kommunikation lässt sich nicht unterbinden, und so lässt sich auch Kommunikation über solche Märkte nicht unterbinden. Da es ein Interesse daran gibt, bei den Marktteilnehmern den Markt günstig zu halten, gibt es auch ein Interesse zur Kommunikation. Dann wird Kommunikation stattfinden. Man kann natürlich das Internet ausschalten. Aber das ist ja keine Alternative.
Aber apropos Interesse zur Kommunikation, hier rufen nämlich gerade Leute an. Die anderen, die noch anrufen, wollen die Nummer gerade nicht wissen. Die hören jetzt bitte zu. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Unterrichtung. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio.
Ich habe ein paar Fragen zum MojoNation. Also, die erste Frage ist, ich habe mal gehört oder gelesen, dass bei MojoNation die Daten, die immer eingespielt wurden, die hochgeladen wurden, permanent gespeichert werden und nicht mehr gelöscht werden können. Besteht da nicht das Problem, dass dann MojoNation ganz verboten werden. Ist ja durchaus denkbar, dass jetzt irgendwelche illegalen Sachen hochgeladen werden und die dann nicht mehr gelöscht werden können aus dem Grund.
Also das mit dem nicht ganz löschbar ist nicht richtig. Es ist in der Praxis sehr, sehr schwierig, etwas zu löschen. Wie ich erwähnt hatte, wird das Fall ja in acht Teile gesplittet, die auf acht verschiedene Server abgeloadet werden. Mindestens vier davon brauchst du, um das wiederherstellen zu können. Und du kannst natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das File wiedergefunden wird, dadurch erhöhen, dass du es auf mehr Server abgeloadest. Und wenn diese Server alle in verschiedenen Ländern stehen, zum Beispiel, die alle unter einer verschiedenen Gerichtsbarkeit liegen, dann ist es natürlich sehr, sehr schwierig, gegen alle gleichzeitig vorzugehen. Das heißt, es ist schwierig, da rechtlich etwas gegen diese Daten zu machen. Es ist aber de facto so, dass es technisch gesehen schon löschbar ist. Und naja, man kann natürlich versuchen, MojoNation zu verbieten, aber Software zu verbieten, funktioniert nicht. Da ich würde sie nicht aus der Welt geschafft. Ja, sie versuchen es auch, aber es funktioniert nicht. Also DCSS beweist, dass es nicht geht, eine Software, nachdem sie einmal im Internet ist, wieder aus dem Internet rauszukriegen.
DCSS für alle?
DCSS ist das Programm, um DVDs zu entschlüsseln. Das braucht man nicht zum Kopieren, sondern um sie zu gucken.
Na gut, eine andere Frage hätte ich noch. Das Prinzip von MojoNation ist ja klar, man zieht sich was runter und bezahlt dafür. Jetzt kann das doch aber nicht abgesichert werden, dass jemand, der meinetwegen nichts in den Händen hat, außer den Mojos, die er jetzt bei seinem Standortprogramm jetzt gleich mal dabei hat, jetzt will er Geld machen. Besteht da nicht die Gefahr, dass er sich irgendwas runterzieht und das selber ins Netz stellt, um das zu verkaufen?
Wenn du das als Gefahren findest, er hat natürlich die Möglichkeit, sich was runter zu ziehen, das auf seinen Server zu tun, damit die Attraktivität seines Dienstes zu steigern.
Aber damit polst er den anderen aus, der zuerst was Interessantes vielleicht ins Netz gestellt hat.
Das ist richtig. Es geht bei MojoNation auch in diesem Protokoll nicht darum, den Urheber zu bezahlen, sondern es geht darum, den Distributionweg zu bezahlen, auf eine faire Art und Weise. MojoNation hat aber ein Trinkgeld-Feature eingebaut. Das heißt, du kannst an einen Fall dran schreiben, wer der Urheber ist. Also es ist in der aktuellen Version noch nicht freigeschaltet. Wenn ihr diese Option sucht, das gibt sie noch nicht, aber sie arbeiten dran, mit dem man dem Urheber dann eine bestimmte Summe Geld überweisen kann. Dann gibst du halt einfach Mojos, die lassen sich digital übertragen. Das ist billig, bequem, schnell und an allen Banken vorbei. Und das Modul, das du implementiert hast, heißt übrigens Pay Lars in Anspielung auf den Drama von Metallica, der sich ja sehr negativ über Netzteile äußert hat.
Metallica, das ist die Band, die kein halbwegs normaler Mensch der einen Computer hat noch hört, oder?
Genau.
Na egal, gut, in der dritten Frage habe ich noch.
Und meine letzte. Wie wird das sichergestellt, dass die vier Teile, die für die Reproduktion vernötet sind, wieder vorhanden? Also, dass die wieder zu finden sind irgendwie. Also viele sind ja offline, viele, was ich sichte, von vielen ist der Rechner nur dann an, wenn sie zu Hause sind. Wie kann das sichergestellt werden? Besteht da die Möglichkeit, dass die Redundanz automatisch erhöht wird? Wenn von Jugendwürmern zentral so was bemerkt wird?
Also es gibt keinen zentralen Server. Das große Geheimnis dieses Protokolls ist, dass es keinen zentralen Server gibt und dass es deshalb nirgendwo zentral angreifbar ist. Es gibt aber sehr wohl einen Mechanismus, der so etwas, wie du beschreibst, in Gang setzt. Und zwar ist es so, dass Files, die nachgefragt werden, sehr beliebt sind. Das heißt, dass Server damit Geld verdienen können, weil wahrscheinlich dein Server sowieso total überlastet ist. Das heißt, wenn du einen Blog-Server betreibst, dann guckst du, wer sonst so Blöcke anbietet und kaufst da Blöcke ein, wenn sie begehrt sind und verkaufst sie halt auch weiter. Das heißt, da ist einmal sichergestellt, dass die Daten sich verteilen, wenn sie nachgefragt werden. Also wenn keiner sich dafür interessiert, dann musst du halt dafür bezahlen, dass es das weiter gibt, indem du den Servern Modus bezahlst, dafür, dass sie es da behalten. Aber wenn es beliebt ist, kaufen wir es selbstständig an. Es wird repliziert, damit es nicht verloren geht, damit die Bandbreite da ist und das File zu verbreiten. Und so weiter und so fort.
Da habe ich natürlich jetzt doch noch eine vierte Frage. Also wenn das dezentral ist, wie bekommt man denn da raus, wo solche Blockserver stehen?
Das habe ich vorhin schon mal kurz beschrieben. Es gibt Trecker, diese Trecker sind sozusagen Submaschinen, die kann man auch selber betreiben. Es gibt Meta-Trecker, in denen die Trecker eingetragen sind. Und jeder Meta-Trecker kennt ein paar benachbarte Meta-Trecker.
Also irgendeine zentrale Instanz gibt es also?
Nein, es gibt keine dezentrale Instanz. Es kann ja jeder einen Meta-Trecker betreiben. Es gibt so viele Meta-Trecker, wie benötigt werden. Und jeder kennt sein Nachbarn. Das heißt, es handelt sich nicht um eine hierarchische Struktur, sondern um eine vernetzte Struktur.
Okay, das sind meine Fragen geklärt.
Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ciao. Ein echtes Peer-To-Peer, genau, Netzwerk.
Tja, dann ist das doch gut, dann benutzen wir das. 031 77 97 110 10 Minuten haben wir noch miteinander zu telefonieren. Oder nicht.
Ja, aber Holger musste jetzt was sagen, damit die Kusenda-Ausverleuchtung nicht angeht und die Techniker kein Herzinfarkt sehen.
Genau, die Moderatoren-Falle nennt man sowas auch ganz gern. Aber jetzt rufen auch wieder Leute an. Das rettet mich aus dieser unangenehmen Situation. Guten Abend, hier ist Chaos Radio.
Ja hallo, hier ist nochmal der Sven. Ich wollte nur mal fragen, gibt es denn diese Idee von MojoNation? Ich meine, gibt es irgendeinen abgefahrenen Volkswirtschaftler oder Wirtschaftswissenschaftler, der so ein Modell mal wirklich als wissenschaftliche Theorie veröffentlicht hat? Weil das scheint ja doch ein bisschen mehr als nur diese Idee dahinter zu stecken, bei euch an Philosophie. Oder gibt es dann ja meist doch irgendeinen abgefahrenen Wissenschaftler auf der Welt, der vermeintlich seriös ist, also akademisch anerkannt, und der sowas auch mal irgendwie umgesetzt hat? Und ich wollte einfach mal nur die Information abzocken, wie dessen Name ist, wenn es ihn gibt.
Also wenn du was Interessantes lesen willst, dann solltest du die Publikationen angucken, die ein gewisser Wolfram Engels gemacht hat. Der ist mittlerweile tot, hat aber bis zu seinem Tod an der Uni Köln Volkswirtschaftslehre gelehrt. Und der ist wirklich ein ganz, ganz großer. Und der hat auch Modelle entwickelt, wie zum Beispiel solche Sachen wie Sozialversicherung und sowas in der Richtung, wesentlich billiger, mit einem wesentlich besseren Effekt für alle Beteiligten herzustellen werden. Also Bürgergeld und solche Stichworte.
Also konkret für den Sachverhalt kenne ich nur eine Arbeit, die kräftig ist. Und zwar geht es da um bandbereiten Versteigerungen. Das ist verwandt, aber lange nicht dasselbe. Und es wäre aber in der Tat interessant, da mal drüber zu forschen. Denn wenn man sich das anguckt mit dem Modulation, das ist ja ein geschlossenes ökonomisches System. Ich habe Einnahmen und ich habe Ausgaben. Und da gibt es dann natürlich auch eine Geldmenge. Also die klassischen Geldtheorien funktionieren mit Modulation, die von einer Zentralbank gesteuert werden. Man kann anmerken, dass diese Zentralbank natürlich ein angreifbarer Punkt ist. Aber in der Praxis wird es natürlich mehrere Zentralbanken geben, die miteinander konkurrieren. Das wird Wechselkurse zwischen den verschiedenen Währungen geben.
Sogenannte Dezentralbanken.
Dezentralbanken, genau.
Aber ja, also auf guter Hälfte müsste es dann doch irgendjemanden geben, der mal irgendwo auf der Welt darüber tatsächlich geforscht hat, auch mit mathematischen Modellen.
Ich denke, die mathematischen Modelle sind dieselben, die auch im echten Geldverkehr funktionieren. Weil ja, heutzutage Geld nichts anderes ist als Daten. Nur, dass die Banken sich untereinander vertrauen, sich deshalb eine Zahl rüber schieben, da steht dran 50, dann wissen sie, dass es 50 Mark wert. Und was fehlt, ist die Anwendung dieser mathematischen Modelle auf die konkrete Problemstellung von MojoNation.
Hat MojoNation eigentlich eine Wertschöpfung?
Ja klar, es wird die Dienstleistung bereitgestellt, Daten vorzuhalten.
Ich meine eine Wertschöpfung in dem Sinne, wie es Banken machen.
Na du kannst eine Bank aufmachen. Du kannst ja von der Zentralbank dir Geld holen und kannst das Geld weiterverleihen.
Also gibt es doch Verzinsung.
Das ist wie normales Geld. Wenn wir untereinander einen Vertrag machen, dass es Zins gibt, dann gibt es Zins.
Das wäre möglich. Also kommt nicht vor, aber du meinst, dass das wäre möglich.
Du bittest die Regeln, weil du bittest einen Dienst an, der irgendwie geartet ist, um den MojoNation als Transport benutzt. Was du als bezahlungswürdig erachtest, ist dein Ding.
MojoNation, also diese Mojos verhalten sich im Wesentlichen wie Bargeld. Die Frage ist, hat Bargeld irgendwelche eingebauten Zinsen? Die Antwort ist nein. Es ist so, dass wir einen Vertrag miteinander machen. Wenn ich dir heute 5 Mark gebe, gibst du mir morgen 10 Mark. Wir könnten natürlich auch von diesem Vertrag abkommen und sagen, wenn ich dir heute 5 Mark gebe, gibst du mir morgen 4 Mark zurück. Das ist also alles etwas, was darauf aufbaut.
Okay, aber glaubst du denn nicht, nur als abschließende Bemerkung, dass mit dieser Verzinsung, ich glaube, dieser Holger Kleinen wollte es vorhin auch andeuten, dass damit die Wurzel des Übels schon wieder gelegt worden wäre. Also, sobald es Verzinsung gibt, gibt es auch die Möglichkeit, Geld zu machen, ohne wirklich Dienstleistungen anzubieten. Nur indem man irgendwie mal sich viel Geld beschafft hat und andere Leute, die Geld brauchen, dazu zwingt, einem dafür Geld zu geben, dass man ihnen Geld gibt.
Aber die anderen Leute können doch einfach eine große Festplatte bei sich hinstellen und auch Geld machen.
Wollte ich mal als kritischen Gedanken einwerfen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall richtig.
Die große Festplatte muss ich aber auch erstmal haben.
Ja, aber ich denke, die ganze Zins- und Negativzins- Diskussion, das ist natürlich alles völlig richtig, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Verbesserung des existierenden Modells.
Es ist zumindest transparenter, und das wird es wahrscheinlich auch immer bleiben.
Na gut, alles klar, vielen Dank.
Ja, wir danken. 031 77 91 10 für die paar Minuten. Ich muss jetzt wieder was sagen, damit nicht die Senderausverleuchte angeht. Was?
Hack drauf rum.
Ich kann da nichts für.
Ich auch nicht.
Die Rückkopplung, da konnte Bitch jetzt wieder hüpfen.
Nein, das Problem ist diesmal nicht Apple.
Das Problem ist die Festplatte in deinem Apple Computer.
Genau, diese eine besondere 20 GB Notebook Festplatte, die sich in ganz vielen Computern ganz scheiße fällt. Nicht nur in diesem Computer.
Ich hätte auch gerne eine 20 in meinem Thinkpad, in dem die internen Lautsprecher nicht funktionieren.
Aber ich glaube, Holger hatte noch eine Erleuchtung.
Naja, keine Erleuchtung. Also es wäre ja eigentlich so, es müsste eine Möglichkeit geschaffen werden, innerhalb MojoNation verzeimt zu untersagen. Was natürlich damit keine Wertschöpfung stattfindet.
Aber warum sollten keine Wertschöpfung stattfinden?
Warum soll eine stattfinden?
Warum soll keine stattfinden?
Das ist, weil irgendwann, weil es irgendwann jemanden gibt, der über so viel, über so viel Geld verfügt, oder über einen so großen Anteil, oder einen so großen Teil der Geldmenge, dass er in der Lage ist, auch damit steuernd einzugreifen.
Und deine Theorie, die sich dann zeigt, ist, dass du bei einer Welt, wo die Voraussetzungen sehr unterschiedlich sind, weil in dieser Welt kann nicht jeder einfach, wenn er geboren wird, startet er nicht mit den gleichen Bedingungen, sondern mit höchst unterschiedlichen Bedingungen, wie Eigenkapital, aber auch...
Das hab ich in MojoNation aber auch.
Wo du lebst, das hast du in MojoNation nicht gewünscht.
Doch wenn ich mein Thinkpad da dran hänge, mit 2, 1 Gigabyte, dann verdiene ich bestimmt nicht so viele Mojos, wie du mit deiner 20 Gigabyte Platte.
Oder kannst du dir selben Kanäle anbieten, wie jeder andere.
Und der hat mehr für seine 20 Gigabyte Platte bezahlt. Und vielleicht hast du hier auch eine interessante Dienstleistung zu bieten, für die man kein Geld braucht, sondern nur Zeit, wie zum Beispiel Musik zu machen.
Das läuft auch über MojoNation.
Das könnte man theoretisch machen. Das ist ja nur ein Bezahlprotokoll. Du kannst auch sagen, läuft alles nur über Geld. Und du kannst halt einen großen Topf machen, und dann können die Leute eins zahlen. Und wenn genug zusammen ist, dann veröffentlicht du das Stück. Hat Stephen King zum Beispiel sehr erfolgreich getan mit seinem Buch.
Wie viel hat er denn da zusammengekommen?
Genug, um den zweiten Teil zu schreiben?
Einiges, ja. Was wollte er haben? Wie viel Prozent? 30?
Ich glaube, er wollte 75, und es waren dann 80.
Ganz schön viel.
Wobei man da auch zu gut halten muss, dass Stephen King vorher schon einen Namen hatte.
Ja, aber da muss ich jetzt auch vorgehen, dass wenn man vorher keinen Namen hat, man es auch schwierig hat, in derzeitigen Systemen irgendetwas zu verkaufen, es sei denn, man gibt viel für Marketing aus, dann ist es wieder so der Teufelscheiß, auf den großen Haufen. Oder man macht die beste.
Tja, gerade ein Anschiss, Tim, schäme dich.
Was, jetzt bin ich der Böse?
Das war Chaosradio 56. Mitch, lass den Kopfhörer ran, dann haben wir auch keine Rückkopplung. Das war Chaosradio 56, die Geburtstags- sendung, 5 Jahre Chaosradio. Und wie viele Jahre, Tim, brittelhaft?
Andere Sende, auf jeden Fall gute Gelegenheit, nochmal auf unseren Kongressen zu weisen. Wir haben vom 27. bis 29. Dezember den Kongress in Berlin. Und auf www.ccc.de.com gibt es alle Informationen darüber. Und wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr kommt.
Ja, ich komme dann mal. Und wir hatten fest benutzt, MojoNation.
Na vielleicht sollte man dazu sagen, dass das alles momentan noch sehr, sehr alpha ist.
Noch sehr, sehr alpha, das klingt auch schön.
Und setzt euren Julius unter die Europa gegen Softwarepatentepetition bitte.
Genau, sag mal mal den Link.
petition.eurolinux.org Gute Nacht.
In drei Minuten dann hier der Night Flag.